so Donald Trump shows up in East
Palestine Ohio bringing food water and
Big Macs I kid you not he apparently
came out and said we're gonna get
everybody some McDonald's and I
appreciate it man I'm watching this
video of trump he's getting a hero's
welcome he's getting a presidential
welcome and he's actually helping people
call it whatever you want call it a
photo op call it opportunism call it
campaigning don't know don't care if I
see the president the United States
leave this country to Ukraine with 500
million dollars in cash for a foreign
country and ignore the people of this
country I'm gonna look to anybody who's
helping it out which is why I've
repeatedly given a shout out to Benny
Johnson who shut up and gave out twenty
thousand dollars he did more than Joe
Biden did and he's just some internet
guy Donald Trump actually showed up
means a lot so we're going to talk about
that and a whole lot more Joe Biden once
again fell up the stairs I'm not kidding
Joe Biden literally fell up the stairs
again
okay we got a bunch of other stories too
uh so we'll get into all this but the
big story right now obviously is East
Palace East Palestine Donald Trump uh
the presidency politics and all this
stuff so we're gonna get into all that
before we get started head over to
timcast.com to become a member and
support our work go there at timcast.com
click that little join us button in the
left become a member
tonight around 10 10 or so after we wrap
the live stream we will have a Live
members only uh show so we initially
would pre-record the members only
segment put it up for members but now it
is live because we figured it out and we
are working on a private Discord for
members meaning a private chat for
people who want to hang out and chat 24
7 and then this will be the chat room
for the Live members only show with the
ability to bring in callers so you can
ask our guest questions as well I think
that's a brilliant idea that was Ian's
idea to do Collins I think that's
brilliant it adds a new dynamic dynamic
to the show so we do the main show we
hang out we talk then afterwards those
who want to hang out and watch
additionally and maybe have more
questions we can actually get you on to
talk with with the uh the gas I think
really great so again become a member at
timcast.com hopefully we'll have that
whole system up and running by next week
for the time being we don't have the
live chat set up we just have the live
numbers only but we're getting there and
with your support we're gonna do more
awesome stuff so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is Mark
owsley hello hello thanks for having me
man who who are you good sir well I am
host of the unwelcome podcast add an
invokablepod on YouTube Twitter uh
citizen journalists and probably the
least famous person to be on Tim cast
IRL but I appreciate being here wow
we've had like Specialists today you
know yeah I know but no followers no
yeah so I got I got a few followers but
I mainly do work uh with education and
advocacy for kids and students in in
Oklahoma Red State so right on yeah well
glad to have you should be fun we also
got Phil Labonte hanging out I follow
you mark hi what's up I am Phil from All
That Remains uh uh Phil that remains on
Twitter and uh I'm here to give my
opinion
here we go I have Ian Crossland I last
night I said some harsh things about
Donald Trump one of which I should say I
don't like talking about people when
they're not here I want to say anything
I would say about someone I will say to
your face when I see you Donald I said
that I called you a lot I love you never
change please never jail I called you a
liar I think that just because you told
a lie in the past doesn't mean that you
are a liar still it means that you lied
so I I'm not going to judge you or call
you names or any of that I want to meet
you thank God what you're doing in East
Palestine right now brother
um and we can go from there we'll go
deeper into that on the show if you guys
wanna we got Serge Dupre on the buttons
yes uh nice Ian I like that that was
cool
um I'm excited to say that me and Phil
will be on pop culture crisis tomorrow
yes we will sweet so check that out um
ready to start the show when you are all
right we got the story from timcast.com
Trump receives presidential welcome from
East Palestine officials renders relief
amid Biden's absence from a region Trump
this is really America right here we are
standing in America and boy is he
correct former president Donald Trump
has traveled to East Palestine to survey
the damage and Recovery efforts
following the 38-car derailment of a
Norfolk Southern Train carrying
hazardous materials officials from East
Palestine welcomed the former president
with the chief of the East Palestine
fire department offering him a briefing
one might expect President Joe Budden to
receive were he not otherwise occupied
in foreign territories who wrote this
one Brett McDonald I love the just like
it's kind of a jab without being a jab
it's just a factual statement check out
check out how the daily wire wrote it up
I love this one from Daily Mail I know
this menu better than all of you Trump
orders Big Macs or East Palestine First
Responders and himself after delivering
13 pallets of food and Trump water to
families betrayed by Biden after toxic
train disaster obituary
I'm sorry man uh where's the picture of
the this is great Trump standard
McDonald's order two Big Macs two filet
of fish and a chocolate shake that is
horrible wow the Flair fish is like
delicious but like but that's a lot of
food for one person where's the picture
of the Trump order they got Trump water
look at this Trump water
I love it of course this this is what I
absolutely love about Trump
he will come down and he will help all
of these desperate people and He will
slap his name on the water bottle yeah
brilliant well to be fair this is what
really annoyed me during the Trump
Administration among many other things
they would mock Trump over Trump water
Trump magazine and Trump stake and what
they wouldn't tell you is that this was
these were brand products for his Golf
Resorts yep so when you go to Walmart
and they've got the Walmart brand it's
good great value or whatever when you go
to a grocery store and they have their
name there that's all it is they were
acting like Trump was selling Trump
water in grocery stores so I went to
Trump Doral once and they were all to
all the Liberals were like Trump water
went out of business and Trump magazine
is gone I walk in I walk in the hotel
room and I look down at the table on
this Trump magazine the bottle of trump
water and I'm like what are these people
talking about these are companies that
Donald Trump owns that provide these
materials to his Resorts so Trump has a
bunch of these water bottles probably
from a bunch of different Resort
properties and he said grab what we got
ship it out every everybody knows that
you go into a hotel and there's bottles
of water
and it'll have the hotel's brand name on
it typically not not always depending on
the the the tier the star rating or
whatever but Trump has pallets of water
at these hotels and just had load up on
my truck we'll pay for shipping and then
we can give these to people who need
them win win win for everybody yep well
anything they can do to make them look
bad that's what they're going to do and
and they'll they'll stretch the truth or
just an outright lie about it but one
thing I did like about this was that
this is the first sign that I've seen of
2015-2016 trump oh yeah in a long time
because he's been really out of the loop
he was kicked off Twitter kicked off
Facebook that's not his fault but that
left him with it left him unconnected
from what made him president you know
and so this is the first signs of life
I've seen going back to that kind of old
school what made him president in 2015.
I don't see anything negative about what
he just did this is amazing negative has
there been lash like I'm not seeing any
any what can the corporate press say
about Trump right now to bring him down
yeah but here's the thing if they come
out and I'm sure they could come up with
something to attack Trump over but all
that would serve to do is highlight that
Trump is there and Biden is not and
where's Booty judge did he show up no
yeah you know what I don't care if it's
a photo op I literally don't care he
brought water with him by all means if a
photo op means people in need get the
help they need then that's better
leadership than what Biden is offering I
certainly wouldn't call it a photo it'd
be a photo if he was there looking
around and they took pictures but this
is he's giving people life life
sustenance right he's also giving them
air you know he's giving them air time
that they normally wouldn't get and and
that's been the problem right now we
were all talking about Chinese balloons
while this was happening and you know
I'm sure that's a serious thing but it
seemed to overshadow this giant uh this
giant uh
problem that was going on in Ohio and
that nobody was talking about until well
after the fact and so I I commend him
photo if it is a photo op because it
sure it shines a light on the problem
let's say it's a photo up Biden couldn't
give a damn to take a picture yeah Biden
couldn't show up for 10 minutes get a
picture and leave he could not even do
that
Ukraine's very important you know uh how
many people in the United States can
point to Ukraine on a map yeah how many
people United States can tell you can
name three cities in Ukraine or any uh
what do they say oblast is that is that
the territories they use I don't know
States
most people don't even know what it is
or where it is and many of these people
are flying the flag but I tell you this
ask somebody where Ohio is to be honest
a lot of people might not wear nowhere
Ohio is but most Americans probably do
and they know it is America and my
question is just Why uh why are my tax
dollars going to Ukraine and not to East
Palestine
this is all good for Trump like there's
no downside to this and everything that
that President Biden is doing right now
is at best only popular with the
Democrats and with his base and so I
just like you can't you can't criticize
Trump for any of the stuff he's doing
it's it's it's it's it's all like you
said 2016 Trump it's all good Trump it's
all all exactly what he needs and the
even the remarks he's making and the you
know he's being that funny kind of same
dude that people that like Trump really
really like the every man Trump you know
even though he's a billionaire right
that he can connect with people that
aren't billionaires and that's you know
he grew up in New York and and that's
part of that culture and so I think
that's what's been missing from his
campaign and from his Persona since he's
really been cut off from the American
people in in the way that made him
popular in the first place you know my
favorite story was the well done steak
with ketchup and how the corporate press
attacked him for it those that are
long-standing fans of the show have
heard me mention the story probably a
dozen times but Trump was ragged on by
CNN because he ordered a it was like a
38 30-day dry aged steak well done with
ketchup and I'm just like a lot of lower
lower and working-class people who get
steaks from the grocery store that are
not high quality we'll cook it through
and splash ketchup on it because they
can't afford a 30-day dry aged filet
mignon or or you know whatever
Donald Trump was basically signaling to
regular working people he ate the way
they ate and they mocked him for it and
when they went on TV and said Donald
Trump what it would an idiot for doing
this the people sing at home were
cutting into their well done steak with
ketchup gone
why you're making fun of me like I'm
literally doing this right now Trump
trump knew how to play them this is when
he just we need to see more of but I
want to show you this too this one
matters this story right here
from WTAE ABC Giant Eagle pulls Water
bottled near East Palestine from store
shelves now why is that why would a
grocery store remove water bottles from
a spring that was near East Palestine
from their store shelves why would they
stop selling water
that was uh near this toxic waste dump
if the water is safe to drink the water
is fine that's what they said and uh and
the air is fine but this store won't
sell you the water you know I'll tell
you this if the government comes out and
tells you the water's safe and then you
drink it and you get sick why would they
care if you sue them they're giving you
your money back to you it's your tax
dollars oh no we got sued here's your
money back here's the money we took from
you back now if giant eagle gets sued
uh-oh that's their profits that's coming
out of their shareholders pockets so
what I see is when the private sector
says get the water off the shelves
they're seeing something wrong when the
government says everything's fine go
ahead and drink the water they're
probably lying who was it that did the
video where they dragged JD Vance JD
Vance drag a stick across the bottom of
a river and you see all the oils and
chemicals come up to the surface and
these colored rainbow okay that's still
that's still in the muck and what does
this mean when you talk about water
you're talking about food too oh yeah I
mean Farmland chicken is everything
that's out all around there but just the
the food the crops that are going to
grow around this place that would go out
to probably grocery stores all over the
country and definitely in Ohio you know
what does it mean for the food supply
fortunately I don't think it's gonna be
that bad relative to what nuclear
Holocaust or like Chernobyl because what
I'm reading about the uh the chemicals
is that they have a very short half-life
like uh what was the main one vinyl
chloride has like a 2.3 day Half-Life so
after a week you've got about 15 15 of
the 25 of the chemicals no after after a
week you've got like 12 and a half
percent of it left in the air and then
after a few more days you've got like
six percent of it left so we've already
seen 98 of the vinyl chloride disperse
out of the air uh it's really their
concern is the benzenes if there were a
lot of benzenes in the in the fires they
said there were not the official report
is that it was Benzene residue I don't
know if you should necessarily believe
the official report but when Benzene
Burns it creates dioxins which are
persistent and those can stay in the air
and in the soil for a long time as far
as I've read Ryan Ellis super chatted
saying politico's already attacking them
and so Politico has this semi-round
about attack on trump it says Trump's
visit to Ohio derailment gives Biden's
team some Breathing Room his planned
appearance near the scene of this most
toxic derailment has Democrats pointing
to his past efforts to roll back train
and chemical regulations and there it is
the corporate press will find a way to
make it a negative thing for Trump man I
I think to get some people some burgers
man man I think it's more indicative of
the fact that we spent a year and a half
calling everything but infrastructure
infrastructure right I mean if there was
a problem with the rail yard and we're
doing this giant infrastructure Bill and
you've got Democrats coming out and
calling you know underwater basket
weaving classes infrastructure right
that you you saw a lot of that so you
had a lot of this this pork that passed
the 1.2 trillion dollars worth of money
going towards things that had nothing to
do with infrastructure and and this is
what comes of that so they're going to
try to spin it back on him but weren't
we supposed to be fixing the railways
weren't we supposed to be doing that do
you think that if Biden or booty judge
showed up they'd boo him out yes like
just yell at them at this point I don't
know it depends on what they should if
they showed up with huge pallets and
pallets of water and food probably not
you're not you wouldn't see you wouldn't
see Buddha judge or Biden do that why
was Biden not has not gone is it a
health well
District 72 percent of this District
voted for Trump right and I want to
point out Ian's persistent with all due
respect naive day in terms of who these
people really are and you know often on
the show you'll talk about pardoning
people or giving them the benefit of the
doubt and it's like yo man when people
tell you who they are believe them when
Joe Biden sneaks off to Ukraine with 500
million dollars and ignores This
Disaster in its entirety and then
outright his he didn't even address it
his people like you're not coming there
Buddha doesn't even show up he's telling
you outright he does not care about
regular working-class Americans what I
wonder is who who's decide I think of
Biden on a leash when I think about
Biden I don't think he's making the
decisions about whether or not he goes
to East Palestine I feel like someone's
like no it's too risky for your
condition Joe you can't breathe that air
in your 80 85. but they're telling us
that they're safe yeah they're bad
people they're evil people I'd like to
know when this trip was planned you know
was it was it just a last minute thing
to for Trump no foreign
but if it wasn't that could be an
indication that maybe this was an effort
to get eyes away oh you know what I'm
saying I don't know oh I see yeah I had
the feeling that it had been on track
for a while no one knew about it but
they were like just gonna do it on this
day anyway and then the East Palestine
thing was inconvenient to talk about
because it was in the way but you make a
good point maybe they were just like we
need to divert eyes to something now we
need another Chinese balloon right yeah
did he take Hunter with him
over there I don't think he did but no
oh the more the more distraction he can
he can generate from this exactly I just
I 500 million dollars man that would I
mean the people who live near this train
derailment that train company probably
should compensate them for the fair
market value of their properties before
the damage absolutely and they can keep
the property but ain't nobody buying
those houses now right so what do we get
Donald Trump
he shows up
there's a lot of things he'd be playing
golf right now but this is where I think
he's getting back into the swing of
things and uh I got to be honest you
know there's a lot of things Trump do
that I chuckle at Raw my eyes at but
when I saw this video of him coming down
there I got a warm fuzzy feeling inside
I'm like at least someone's doing
something I don't care if Trump doesn't
care maybe he's just like here's a great
opportunity to get attention and I'm
like wow he thinks that helping the
American people will make people like
him Joe Biden just left even he didn't
even care that much just like you said
even if it is just a photo op it's he's
still actually like putting food in
people's bellies and giving people water
so but but but right but I'm what I'm
saying as well is Trump if it is a photo
op he's thinking to himself this will
make people like me yeah okay good yeah
he wants people to like him he has a
concern about whether or not the
American people like him Joe Biden
doesn't no he's just gone yep he doesn't
Biden doesn't seem to care about what
anybody thinks as long as he's keeping
his far Left Flank happy and all right
and maybe he doesn't even care about
that we're gonna we're gonna make fun of
Joe Biden because we have this story
from the New York Post it's big news
breaking news from 11 57 a.m Biden
stumbles up Air Force One stairs again
leaving Poland you know that's karma
that's a that's
someone uh carpet I think Carpe dongta
made a meme where Trump throws his hat
and he's Palestinian and then a
boomerangs around and hits bite and he
falls up the stairs this is what we get
ladies and gentlemen your president not
only abandoning the American people
visiting foreign countries and then
falling up the stairs that's that's your
president to be fair that's a lot of
stairs for a dude that's almost 80. yeah
what are they gonna build an escalator
an escalator what I want to know is
where is SNL on this I mean when when
Gerald Ford fell down the stairs uh in
the 70s when he was president that's
what made Chevy Chase famous was making
fun of Gerald Ford when he fell down the
stairs and it's like this has happened
twice now and you see nothing from
places like SNL or or any of the
comedians making fun of it it doesn't
make any sense to me
the Babylon Beast tearing it up they
have a lot they're one of their new
articles Biden promises to get rid of
these Resort fees wait I'm sorry Biden
promises to get rid of those Resort fees
by the time World War III starts have
you seen him tweeting about getting rid
of Resort fees over the last three weeks
these 90 secret fees are ruining America
under my watch will make sure and it's
like these really your priorities dude
he just he's tweeted about it like three
times in the last two weeks he has
mentioned a couple of things that are
very silly like very frivolous and this
isn't comedy this is true
but juxtaposed with the Ukrainian stuff
in East Palestine it's like what is he
the Babylon bee wrote this headline
Biden promises to get rid of those
Resort fees by the time World War III
starts but that's literally what he's
saying it's like he so he didn't
literally say I will get rid of these
fees before the start of World War III
but world war three is on the we're on
the cusp of a major conflict he's like
don't worry we're gonna get those Resort
fees down it's like what completely
people's whole city is blanketed in this
chemical it killed their livestock and
is like floating in their water and then
you're like Mr President will you help
the poor people of East Palestine I will
by cutting those Resort fees so when
they're evacuating their Hometown it'll
be a little cheaper out of their pocket
maybe they're not making fun of him
falling up the steps because he's old
and it's like elder abuse racism yeah
whereas like Gerald Ford was still how
old was Ford was he like in his early
60s or something no he was even I mean I
think he's in his 50s or something so he
was younger anything he's more of just a
guy falling down right but again it is I
guess a little funny but when you do it
twice man I mean when you do the same
thing twice yeah SNL should be all over
the that and I think Tim is right you
know it is a cult and it just says we
cannot make fun of the Holy One we
cannot make fun of the person that's
carrying our water for us and and it's
really sad it's really sad this is what
uh the president is tweeting about right
now hidden junk fees are taking money
out of the pockets of average Americans
thanks to our efforts most the country's
largest banks are getting rid of fees
for bounced checks we're going to lower
overdraft fees next well that's that's
really great uh I mean cool do you have
anything to add about the people whose
entire city is blanketed in toxic
chemicals and whose livestock are dying
I would be interested to hear what you
had to say about that one I'm curious oh
I'm sorry before that he says our
support for Ukraine will not waver NATO
will not be divided we will not Tire oh
NATO yeah he's not talking about us he's
in what is his Bucharest Bucharest nine
leaders have provided critical security
assistance do you say anything NATO NATO
NATO NATO
uh earlier I was briefed on a winter
storm okay is he just not saying
anything Ukrainian refugees democracies
around the world uh-huh Christians in
Ash Wednesday okay well that one's okay
you know all right I can respect that
one he's talking about Americans at
least yo it's it's like
in it to him none of this even happened
did he even mention it once I maybe it
has to have had mentioned it I thought
he tweeted about it once but while he
was on his way to Ukraine right wow I
mean that that that's an air in the face
you know you got a toxic chemical spill
it's a problem well I'll be over in
Ukraine given 500 million dollars from
your from your taxes to a country you
can't point a toy on a map I think it
was Anna De armas somebody there was an
actor saying that the age of social
media has basically killed the uh the
the movie star it's basically there are
no more movie stars now it's it's a lot
I think a lot less about the art that
you make and more about who you are as a
person because it's a lot more prevalent
and obvious now and it's the same thing
with the president they don't hide
behind this Visage of like the title now
you get to see this guy in his daily
behavior and it's insane look look look
sorry man just look at this picture
this is worse this is like 1970s crap
this this this tweet from Joe Biden is
worse than nothing he said after my
speech did I spoke with EPA Michael
Reagan shared Brown Bill Johnson Shapiro
dewine about our ongoing efforts in East
Palestine Ohio a reaffirmed my
commitment to making sure they have
everything they need let me give you the
latest and there is a picture of him
sitting on the phone and I don't know
where he is but it's just like
bro just do nothing and say nothing
because the very least then we can try
to imagine what might you have been
doing but to be like I got on the phone
with some guys told her just let me know
what you need well thank god this is
worse than a mean tweet you know what I
mean this is this is a a tweet of like
I'm just going to placate you I'm going
to say something so you so I can say I
said something and that's it you know
I'd rather have an outwardly mean tweet
than just something that placates people
who are really going through a hard time
let's be real but I didn't talk to
nobody he probably did nothing it's a
stock photo they probably took of him
weeks ago they probably have a whole
library of photos of him doing other
things you've got remember the picture
of him and it was It was supposed to be
at uh Camp David but then people noticed
the clock was not daylight savings time
and they're like wait a minute this had
to have been taken before March or like
before November or whatever proving that
either well maybe they don't update
their clocks or it was a stock photo of
the president this is probably a stock
photo they bring them in a room and they
say we're gonna get a bunch of different
photos if you're doing different things
to use in different moments I bet the
dude has no idea what's going on in Ohio
I bet he's just like I don't know they
told him we got a plan to fly to Ukraine
he tweeted about it yesterday uh rail
companies have spent millions of dollars
to post Common Sense safety regulations
and it's worked more than a train
derailment more than a toxic waste bill
it's years of opposition to safety
measures coming home to Ruth doesn't
mention Ohio doesn't mention so that's
that's the same talking point as
Politico just put out right I mean it's
all Trump's fault basically right
because of of the of the regulations and
that seems to Obama did the same thing
with bush and I'm you know no fan of
bush but any it was seven years to do as
presidents and he was like oh well Bush
right it something went wrong it was
Bush's fault and that seems to be what
Biden is doing anytime he can just say
oh if it's wrong it's Trump's fault it
has nothing to do with what I've done
you just go back and look at previous
administration yeah I expect that out of
an Administration if they're going to
actually
do that in conjunction with taking
action to help relieve the situation on
the ground if there's going to be like
I'm not a fan of government anyways but
if there's going to be a government
that's that's if there's going to be an
EPA if there's going to be uh you know a
FEMA and stuff why aren't they helping
in the places that in the US that need
their help and the rail system is the
federal government's responsibility and
when you're talking about the the
chemicals and stuff this is the EPA this
is what they do yeah obviously you know
go ahead I was told that he's been
offering Biden's been offering Federal
help to the governors but they they
haven't been requesting it he actually
says in his tweet uh as I said to your
Governors they'll have every resource
that they need indicating that they like
they're available for you Governors if
you need it but what is it is it the
federal government gives a state uh some
sort of FEMA relief then the state owes
the federal government something is it
like a Tit for Tat so the governor's
like I don't want to get involved with
Federal money I don't want you breathing
down my neck about that thing in the
future as a result I mean to some degree
but also like you know we pay taxes and
that's the point of them so that Federal
Emergency Management can come and assist
us when things like this happen but I
would think it would happen with no you
know no per uh Pro like what is it no
expectation of something in return well
I think the governor has to declare some
kind of state of emergency at some point
but other than that if you requested the
age should be offered but I don't know
it it seems all very very strange that
that the federal government didn't jump
in at the beginning it didn't highlight
the issue at the beginning I mean it
seemed like when I first tweeted about
it which was early right I was getting
you know bought replies in my in my feed
saying oh you need to check your sources
on what actually is happening there and
this kind of a false Narrative of
everything is fine the people of East
Palestine are are just making the
mountain out of a mole hill everything's
okay and then it turns out absolutely
that's not the case it took JD Vance
going over there to do it to show people
but again we were fed a narrative or
when we were fed a narrative it turned
out to be completely false I posted I've
retweeted the early image of like the
river the Ohio river and then all the
potentially affected States through the
water table and I just tweeted the image
I said I don't know there's nothing
verifying if this is real or not get
water filters get air filters don't wait
for official confirmation to take care
of yourself and I got a Twitter the next
day a warning said this is unverified
and someone's like Ian you got to worry
I was like I'm fine with it I know I
didn't verify this it's just take care
of yourself but then the next day they
removed the warning so like
that's interesting yeah yeah it was a
big thing where the New York Times
claimed the far-right conspiracy
theorists were saying the water table
was being threatened and I'm like the
governor of Ohio said that he said a
chemical plume is Flowing down river
towards West Virginia are we supposed to
assume that you can drink those
chemicals is that why it's safe not in
the New York Times it's all about the
power of the first impression right it's
it's they put out these these narratives
hoping that okay the people that read
the New York Times are the people that
read The Washington Post they see that
at the beginning and they never look at
it again and anytime they see a story
about it after that they go oh that's
just crazy white right-wing conspiracy
theorists and so it's the power of that
first impression that they're trying to
Marshal there that's it's really
criminal I've got the the notice back on
I think the notice is on the thing I
retweeted it's not on my tweet so it
says the map is a high rear Basin does
not accurately represent areas of
potentially contaminated drinking water
multiple agencies and locales are
actively testing groundwater and
river-based drinking water and have
found no contamination have found no
contamination yet we've seen JD Vance's
video of contamination and a grocery
store is pulling water bottles off the
shelves you I wonder why I think this
notice can come down Twitter
we're going to segue to a new story a
story from the New York Post it's titled
death of shot Clinton aide with Epstein
ties found tied to tree ruled suicide
despite no gun at seen and I want to say
to all of you who are watching this show
and our fans I wanted to open tonight's
show with this story but the big news is
obviously Trump coming down that matters
a lot more to people because it's
directly impacting the lives of people
who are facing this toxic spill so I can
respect that and as much as the Clinton
aide being tied by the neck to a tree
and found shot to death with no gun
being ruled a suicide well this is not
immediately going to impact your life
but it is very very interesting so let
me just let me just stress that again an
individual who worked the clintons uh in
the 90s was found tied to a tree shot in
the chest no gun and they went looks
like a suicide to me so uh I guess he
held the gun to his chest and when he
pulled the trigger it The Recoil blasted
off into the air where it landed on a
small log in the river and then floated
Downstream and eventually over waterfall
where it's just gone maybe he might have
had balloons tied to his gun that's a
good point oh that could have been a
good one he had he had several 100
balloons tied to the gun because
obviously the gun would probably weigh
several pounds did the Warren Commission
do this or somebody's like it's like
it's like the Phantom gun Theory you
know what I mean like if you're tied to
a tree and you've got gunshots is it
more than one gunshot or is it just one
I think is it two well I think it just
said that he was shot and he was shot in
the chest right that's what it was Phil
I don't know so if even if you have a
pistol and you're doing that kind of an
extension cord tying his neck to a tree
with a gunshot wound to the chest that's
what it says I wonder what kind of
gunshots could you imagine like if this
if if this was a suicide and he strapped
balloons to his gun for for okay come on
like clearly he did not do that clearly
this is probably just not a suicide
um maybe there's a bunch of things you
can say maybe too right let's let's play
this game how could someone oh sorry so
he goes up against a tree and he throws
the extension cord around it and then
catches it on the other side and then
ties it and Spins it around so that way
he's tied by the neck then he takes we
don't know what kind of gun hold it to
his chest when he pulls a trigger at
this point several things may have
occurred the gun recoil launched into
the air where I mentioned it lands on a
log and then floats away Downstream to
never be seen again or maybe a bear came
and Like Cocaine bear you saw the gun
and thought to himself with this I will
rule the forest picks the gun up and
then walks away
in reality maybe someone found the gun
and was like hey that's worth money and
then just took it and ran but let's just
play Occam's razor in the absence of
evidence The Simple Solution tends to be
the correct one someone shot him that's
it and took the gun away and right and
then walked away with it
I can't believe that that's even a
headline I I can't believe that that
actually people are expecting to believe
that I mean I I suppose after the
Epstein stuff you know they figure just
whatever I would like I would like to
hear the numbers of the people of the
number of people that commit suicide by
shooting themselves in the chest you
know what I'm saying because I don't
think that from what I've read about
this situation about people who do that
they want it over quickly right if you
shoot yourself in the chest unless you
get yourself right in the heart
it's still a slow process right and so I
I think that should be a question that
they ask as well it's like and not to
mention just the sheer mechanics of if
it was a rifle that it was done with it
well the cop said they found 12 gauge
buckshot in his car and a gun case with
no gun
so then like did he have a shotgun that
is incredibly difficult to do if you I
mean a shotgun is a long long rifle uh
weapon 18-inch barrel if that's why the
SP SBS that's why the the the typical
story is you use your foot yeah that
they they aim with their feet or
whatever I don't want to give away too
much please nobody hurt yourself at home
or anything like that but uh yeah I I
what he I'm sorry it The Recoil launched
us into the air where it attached to a
like a bird catches it and flies away
with it he tied balloons to it I mean
that's that's the only logical
explanation that these cops are to be
right or how about this this guy is
involved in something
and somebody killed him I mean for all
we know look let's be real for all we
know he's banging some dude's wife right
it could be that simple we don't need we
don't need to go back 30 years and be
like here with the clintons he did and
maybe he banged some dude's wife and
someone got revenge on him maybe it was
a sheriff's wife but the sad part about
this is that this is going to put an end
to the to any real questioning about
this you know you may have you know
people like us talking about it but it's
in terms of official investigation this
is done because nobody else has
jurisdiction anything about the clintons
is done before it gets started it's true
what's the Epstein ties did you guys he
signed Epstein into the White House
apparently like a dozen times something
like that
see I don't think that someone was going
to commit suicide would tie their neck
around a tree first yeah it was very
weird or tie balloons to the gun I mean
unless he was just like I hate this
world and I'm gonna confuse the hell out
of everybody I looked up uh New York
Post Clinton AIDS suicide and it gave me
other people's names as well Mark Rich
Vince Foster Mark Middleton Mark
Middleton that's who was not Mark
Richman Vince Foster yeah I mean twice
in the back of the head or something
like that it was there was uh who was
the guy who was the journalist who was
investigating the CIA or whatever like
the crack stuff and then he got shot
twice in the head and they rolled it a
suicide
you want to look that one up yeah
what was that guy's name like there's
just so many of these stories and then
uh I was mentioning I've been watching
Yellowstone and so this isn't really a
spoiler because this is like first
season first episode stuff but they kill
a lot of people in that show and they
just kick them off a mountain and it's
like ain't nobody gonna find these
people you know this is Gary Webb is
that Gary Webb two gunshots to the Head
rule to suicide by the Sacramento County
coroner's office and that's it for that
investigation okay you know what I mean
that's done it could be like in South
Park there was that episode where the
guy was trying to kill himself and then
shoots himself like oh oh no I'm still
alive and then he keeps trying or
whatever like okay whatever but I just I
got Occam's razor this one and just be
like typically when someone's shot twice
in the head it's not a suicide so why
would they be like nah you know suicides
or whatever jeez Gary Webb wrote what is
this the dark Alliance series uh examine
the origins of the crack cocaine trade
in Los Angeles and anti-communist Contra
Rebels and Nicaragua yeah you know we
don't want people finding that about
that so the drug trade feeling
is selling crack and cocaine in in the
United States do you think what
percentage of our economy you think is
like drugs is that taking Pharma would
that take care well I mean I think big
Pharma accounts for like probably 10
some ridiculous number I think the
healthcare industry itself is 20 is huge
but that's but that's not just drugs
yeah those are those are illicit drugs
not illness no no it's not all drugs the
the 20 of the economy is medical meaning
like when you go to a doctor to get your
legs set you know or get you know
ibuprofen for your bad headaches mental
health yes yeah and all the Praises for
that are all inflated because the
government being involved and stuff in
here there's no Market you know in the
US but yeah
well you think like this this drug trade
from Central America is like a portion
of the economy that like black budget
economy we just don't know about of
course they get exposed of course I
think it is I mean there's there's
always dark money you know and it comes
from all sources but when you when you
get into situations like this just like
Tim was saying you know it could it
could not be Clinton related uh it's
like look this guy went to the Clinton
30 30 some odd years ago right they're
bringing up he was a Clinton aide
because of the conspiracy theory and
that's what I've said about the
conspiracy theory and the clintons are
high profile people who've worked in
multiple agencies and in government of
course they're gonna have connections to
a lot of people now the question is take
someone of comparable public stature and
then calculate how many deaths and
suicides have exist around them in their
periphery and then do that several times
is it different I think what happens is
yeah the clintons are shady people
but it's just like I've seen stories
where it's like a security guard who
worked for a financial firm that Clinton
once used was found dead and I'm like
okay well hold on there buddy we're
getting a bit Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon
on this one did they work with them or
with their organizations if there's a
lot of that that's weird but they're
just bringing up a guy who died recently
and being like he worked for the
clintons 30 years ago and it's like
you're telling me that he still works
for the clintons or something well and
this is just compounded by the whole
Epstein connection I mean they're still
trying to claim that he you know killed
himself right I mean and you know all
the tapes just weren't working all the
videos weren't working this should say
former Clinton aide Minsk says Tim don't
forget to give the disclaimer talk to a
doctor and find out if associated with
the clintons is right for you I think
the doctor would say no no no don't do
that didn't he die in Arkansas too is
that what it was that's what I think was
really yeah he Perryville Arkansas May
2nd 2022 almost one year after his death
a police report obtained by the outlet
revealed that the Little Rock
businessman was discovered with a
gunshot wound to the chest and extension
cord tying his neck to a tree 3. the
extension cord was tied to the tree a
tree limb above him so did he like throw
it over and then like slip knot it pull
it tied around his neck and then lean
back and then shoot himself like you
know could this be auto-erotic
asphyxiation gone wrong I mean you know
like I mean it just it just seems so
very strange maybe the real story is
that like it was auto erotic
asphyxiation but then like a loved one
was like I can't let it be known that he
died this way so they shoot him when he
was already dead
yeah it's an explanation there was some
celebrity who died from that and they
wouldn't admit it they were like oh is
it a heroin singer nxs was it was it
really I think it was the singer in
excess he was joking himself while
joking this is the family-friendly show
so was it Cornell was Cornell doing that
too I don't think so no okay good yeah I
think that was heroin I think Chris yeah
I think that was heroin wasn't he died
on an airplane it was a suit I heard it
was a suicide I don't I had never heard
the about cause of death though so is
that an all overdose or something
no I don't know I don't know I've also
heard other stories about what that
might have been so I'm gonna not get
into enough Cornell yeah not just that
but like a lot of other people too it's
just you know us of course
dark and Not So Family yeah you think
that having the word Clinton in the
headline of this is sensationalist yes
absolutely yeah absolutely
sensationalist journalism is destroying
the universe yes
destroying the universe well I think
it's destroying our political system I
think I think that everything is about
getting clicks and and you have this
giant push for okay how many CL and this
is right and left that's what gets so
fresh I live in a red State okay and and
politicians or just journalists will
automatically put out the most
Sensational headline that they can and
the the body of the story has nothing to
do with what the headline has to do and
this is in red States you know and it
gets very frustrating for people who
like myself are just trying to find the
truth about what's actually happening in
your community and because all this
stuff becomes smoke and mirrors and I
think that Republicans taking kind of
the woke the the woke cue from things
from 2019 2020 when everything just got
out of hand have said well we're just
going to jump on the bad wagon you know
conservative media sometimes does that
and I think it's it's not doing us any
favors it's not doing us any favors to
actually find out the truth of what's
going on that's kind of like if if a
weapon was given to your opponent your
the opposing Army but what the weapon
does is hurt everyone a little bit right
and they use it and they use it you're
like well that thing is destroying us we
need it too so then you start using it
everyone's getting hurt I mean it's
everyone you're people too right that's
what it feels like and you're so it's
self-harm over time because then people
stop trusting you you know and the more
the politicians dig into that you get in
in the local communities you know in
places like Oklahoma you just lose trust
for for the people that you've elected
and you know these people right these
are your local elected officials but
they're participating as much as as
anybody on the national level sometimes
more the disassociation and not trusting
and not knowing your uh local
politicians I think is something that
that people in cities are familiar with
and used to whereas people in small
towns it's easier to access your your
local politicians if there's only five
thousand ten thousand people in your
town as opposed to if you're you know in
New York City or in Cleveland lender or
whatever you know like people in we're
talking about um East Palestine there's
only 5 000 of them they can they can
access the politicians and let them know
that they're upset really easily they
can but it's a that's a double-edged
sword because sometimes you get local
politicians who are friends with
everybody sure and right and they will
just
say what everything it kind of on the on
the blanket of that trust on the
foundation of that trust and oftentimes
you'll see if you really investigate it
that what they're saying is not
necessary and I'm not talking about
anybody specifically I'm just saying
I've seen this over and over again where
they use this Hometown Spirit okay if
you're running in this District you've
got 10 000 people in your District you
know all their names you know all the
families and you go out and you say you
know well this is what this bill does
and you actually read the bill and it
does the complete opposite that that
gets weaponized too and so I I would
just encourage anybody from my
experience read your bills your local
bills because they're the ones that uh
the local laws that are passed on your
behalf from your local politicians
because those are the ones that directly
affect you yeah make sure they're doing
what it is they say they're doing I've
been thinking about sensationalizing the
titles of our show like this show
because like what if the name of the
show is just number 713 and would we get
as many views Lex Friedman we might not
we might get more yeah exactly because
Lexus shows off the chains popular Rogan
he doesn't put any he just puts the name
of the person in the video and the
number huge views like if you know the
person you trust them and you like it's
it's more about the people than about
what the what right but but you come to
Tim cast to find out because I think
this show has done a great job I started
watching around 2020. you know and I'm
and you're a left-leaning person I was
more right-leaning right and I I
appreciated the fact that I could see
what you were talking about and then I
could see your mind change you know on
different things that that that it
opened up you were opening up people's
eyes while you were opening up people's
eyes about things and I think that
that's the benefit of having that kind
of if you want to call it sensationalism
you know on a show like this it's it's
because you hit people from all sides
here you know what I mean it's it's this
is this is a topical cultural commentary
and political commentary and news
commentary right if we were just a show
about
talking to each other and having a
hangout the titles will be very
different
so that's why Lex Friedman's show is
literally him talking to a guy Joe Rogan
is him talking to a person or I
shouldn't say a guy but people so it's
just the the name of the person and
that's and that's what you go for so the
new show that we're doing you know
Friday's culture war with Tim pool
youtube.com timcast is probably just
going to be titled culture War number
one Ali London culture War number two
guest guest guest to come because those
are just conversations and hangouts I
guess do you do you stress about being
too sensationalist when you make
internet video titles a little bit we've
talked about it before I mean I've got
my limit clearly the most successful
channels on YouTube have no qualms
whatsoever about saying the craziest
garbled nonsense you know what one thing
Mr Beast does really well is his titles
will be outlandishly awesome but then in
the first 10 seconds he'll back up the
title he'll let you know this you are
about to see what the title says it's
this get ready so you know like your
your expectations are met right away
apparently that's a huge part of as with
many things there are people who
naturally are Sensational and they have
no idea what they're doing and why it
works but they get a lot of traffic then
there are people who consciously try to
figure out how to create better better
titles and headlines to attract more
people and they get called scummy for
being manipulative it's like well should
we just leave it to those who are
accidentally manipulating people or
should people make headlines that are
attractive I have I have a limit you
know clearly uh but they're strangely
we've had instances where it's like the
new story is you know Donald Trump
delivers Big Macs like I'll make the the
title just that and someone will be like
clickbait and I'll be like
what you did refers to omitting
information from a title in order to get
people to click it so that they can
figure out what's going on rage bait is
a reference to intentionally over hyping
something to shock people make them
angry so they click it and then and then
watch and then of course you know click
bait could also refer to if uh Donald
you know Joe Biden's trips going up the
stairs titling the video Joe Biden has
horrific fall
nearly dies and then it's a video of him
stumbling and going like that's most of
the internet though let's jump to the
story here's one uh this headline is not
sensationalized from the post-millennial
Arizona Rancher charged with murder of
Mexican man was quote hunting migrants
with AK-47 prosecutors prosecutors
allege that Kelly hunted the group of
men with his gun and made numerous
alterations to his story when later
spoke to law enforcement
so you may have heard the story this guy
George Allen Kelly 73 is being charged
with murder because a guy was uh who was
on his property was shot they say he did
it it was an illegal immigrant with
numerous felony Crossings I guess and uh
the issue now apparently is they're
saying he hunted these migrants down to
kill them
yeah what I find strange is that Arizona
I'm pretty sure is a defensive property
State meaning you can kill someone to
defend your property like if someone is
about to cross onto your property my
understanding is that you have a right
to use a lethal Force if they don't stop
so what's strange about this case is
that here's a guy who's on his own
property clearly someone's breaking the
law they end up shot and dead
but this guy gets arrested I'm wondering
how does that make sense
well he was trespassing right I mean
that then in the country and the land
right well and that's why I I know Vivek
ramaswamy just announced for president
and he talks about uh the difference
between immigration and illegal
immigration or people coming across the
border uh illegally and I think that's
the Crux of the matter here is is this
guy he's crossed the border illegally
and then he's crossed into somebody's
property illegally right and this guy's
defending his property he has a right to
do that as opposed to somebody who goes
through ins and goes through the process
to get the green card and does all of
that and I think that underscores what
we were just talking about about the
need to be precise in our language right
and and that's why I kind of like bevec
and him coming out and uh running for
president now you know but it is to be
precise in our language and and
understand what is happening here is why
you uh see so much confusion about
situations like this you know and the
media just seems to play into that this
guy says that uh he just fired warning
shots and there's no evidence that his
bullets hit the guy which to me sounds
like he might be telling a lie that
maybe he did go out there to shoot the
trespassers but now he's afraid that if
he says it out loud he'll go to jail for
sure so he changed his story but when
you change your story then you look like
a liar that's that's kind of what I'm
looking at the path of this situation at
the moment I think the Biden
Administration and Democrats want more
illegal immigration for a variety of
reasons one so they can increase the
population in their States they're
bringing these people in putting on
planes and flying them to swing States
and blue States and they also want the
short-term economic demand bringing in a
whole bunch of people and putting them
cities will create temporary short-term
demand followed by stagnation and
economic crisis but that short-term gain
looks good for them on paper they can
use it to get reelected and the
long-term gain is bringing in a bunch of
people who will increase the census
numbers giving them more Electoral
College votes and congressional seats so
when a guy who lives there says hey get
off my property they're coming right for
me they go this guy needs to be made we
need to make an example of him so that
people don't screw with our agenda you
take a look was it for uh McAllen Texas
at where it's at where under the bridge
they have all the they had all those
people the body Administration clearly
is happy with what's going on people
talk about the southern border and Biden
letting us down or failing or whatever
and it's like no he's doing exactly what
he intended to do the whole time this is
100 by Design This is the intent of the
Democrats they have had
full authority to do something for two
years they have done nothing they did
nothing during the Obama Administration
this has been the Democrats plan for the
better part of the past 20 years to have
a cheap labor be imported into the
country that that's it's it's completely
clear I I can't take anyone that argues
against that seriously it's been going
on for 250 years to the Southern States
imported cheap labor through the African
slave trade yeah and wanted to use those
numbers
okay brother always different stuff
it is they wanted to use those numbers
you can say truthfully that bringing
slaves in was quote unquote cheap labor
but
migrants coming here is not the same as
slaves Avery migrants are coming here of
their own volition like they're walking
like they don't want to do it like there
weren't a lot of people that were in
Africa that were like you know I'm gonna
go to America and be a slave it wasn't
they weren't running out and jumping on
the slaves Heavenly worse as soon as
Biden got elected or it looked like he
was going to be elected and become
president you had a mass migration from
Central America all the way up through
because they knew that they were going
to be allowed to come through and before
that you had remained in Mexico they had
shirts that said please let us in Biden
or whatever right that one yeah no it
they asked for it and you know Kamala
Harris comes out and says well don't
come
right and of course they're going to
listen they they can even hear what
she's saying right I mean they they
they're not sitting there you know on
their phones going oh well Kamala said
not to go let's go back you know I mean
it's like one of the best memes of that
year yeah look at this the reason I
brought to these the reason I brought up
the African slave trades because the
numbers padding that they're doing with
the census like what the sub I I
erroneously said that they said all
black people were worth three-fifths of
a person in the eyes of God two nights
ago that's not what it was about it was
about the north trying to say like look
we're not going to let you pad your
stats for the states with your slaves
we'll say there were three-fifths of a
person each legally just so he wasn't
even out there weak in slavery and so
now we've been North the north said
they're not voting people because
they're slaves the South South said yes
they are and then they agreed on
three-fifths right they were property
the South wanted us to call them
property whatever but now we've got
people that are padding stats one for
one they're not legal citizens so what
do we need another three-fifths Clause
do we need to say no how about no don't
break the law right how about just
enforce the existing laws that right the
problem that's it Sanctuary States
because existing laws
illegal the the the federal government
has whether or not you agree with like
open Borders or not currently the
federal government is the organization
charged with protecting the borders and
enforcing border law and they are
completely and totally neglecting to do
that well and I think you're seeing good
signs come out of places like Texas
where you have Governor Abbott you know
saying if you're not going to do it
we're going to do it you know and we're
going to send the National Guard or send
you know the Texas Marshals down there
to help enforce but when you when you
don't have a barrier right I mean if
when you don't have something to keep
them out in places that because you
can't put eyes on every inch of the
Border all the time it's impossible so
it it the federal government is leaving
this to the states knowing that they
probably can't handle it economically
and it it absolutely is a plan it's been
working for a long long long time
Sanctuary States basically means they're
not part of the Union when California
says we will not abide by Union law it's
like well then why are we why are you in
any way tied to this Union
interposition let me just play Devil's
Advocate what about the marijuana laws
because like you have what 40 States now
that have said that marijuana is legal
but the federal government says agreed
you know I mean it's it's interesting
Federal government's Got Deep problems
yeah yeah that's the idea of
interposition where a state's supposed
to step in and say we supersede your
federal law which is technically the way
the country works so in that in that
instance California can say yeah even if
you're acting xenophobic we're going to
let whoever we want then Texas should
have the right to deport
and the problem is what we're hearing
from border states is that they have no
Authority in deporting people Texas is
deporting to New York and yeah
all that's doing is putting illegal
immigrants in deeper into the country
and embedding them here yeah they're
helping Joe Biden and Democrats and
convincing their voters they're helping
their voters so you get all these
Republicans going like Yay haha it's so
funny they're doing this meanwhile
Biden's like this is awesome yeah this
is fantastic for us we're gonna we're
gonna inflate our numbers in these in
these jurisdictions and New York is
going to get more Congressional votes
it's going to get more Electoral College
votes thank you Texas thank you Florida
I do think that that there is there is a
little bit of of risk in classifying all
people that are migrants as
automatically a Democrat voter
especially considering the especially
considering the push with with LGBT uh
issues gender ideology that's not going
to fly with the Catholics coming up from
uh from South America and also you and
there's also a lot of of people from a
lot of different parts of the world now
are coming through the U.S border I've
heard people from heard about people
from Syria and from Turkey already
getting there because of the earthquake
so it's as long as that border is open
there's going to be people from all over
the world going to you know coming to
South America and then making the Trek
up through Mexico the remain in Mexico
policy will remaining in whatever you
know whatever the safest country that
you can get to that's the correct policy
if you want to if you want to apply for
Asylum that's that's it that's the one
to do I think that we should have them
personally I think we should have a much
easier system for getting people to to
immigrate to the US I think that you
know I'm generally I like the idea of
open borders I do think there probably
has to be some kind of immigration
control but overall I think free people
should be able to move wherever they
want but the system that we have now is
not working at all when I'm thinking
about the sense this I think when you
fill out the census you don't have to
put if you're a citizen is that right is
that the way they changed it now there's
no like is there a census or is there a
citizen block and you can either say yes
I remember
held out in some places well if you
don't put that you're a citizen then
your your Census count should be worth
three-fifths of a person or nothing and
Donald Trump tried getting that on the
census and they sued and the Supreme
Court said you can't do they wanted to
prevent him from forcing people to
acknowledge that they weren't citizens
I'm just saying you don't have to
acknowledge if you are you're not but if
you don't acknowledge that you are then
your censorship you wanted to put the
question on the census and they blocked
him saying you can't right that's what
it was I understand that because if
people had to say no then they'd just be
a target for ice well they wouldn't have
filled that out so you're saying people
who are here illegally breaking our laws
should just be allowed to keep wrecking
our laws
I don't personally feel like that but
that's I think the it's a ridiculous
argument that it's like well if someone
is committing serious felonies we
shouldn't force them to tell us yes you
should the cop
bind them and arrest them and that's it
well and if you aren't a citizen of the
United States you aren't necessarily
protected by the Constitution you are
you you absolutely are protected by the
Constitution if you're not a citizen
Constitution applies to anybody in this
country it doesn't matter if you're
citizen or not and I'm fine with that
the issue however is if you are not a
citizen of this country and you are here
illegally or your Visa well but then you
have a right to sell not
self-incriminate you could plead the
fifth so to speak but yeah right because
right so you get the census with the
question on it and you don't fill it out
yeah but the idea that you can't put the
question in the census is insane and the
argument for the left was well then
people who are not citizens won't fill
it out and we'll get inaccurate readings
and it's like so the people who are here
illegally you we won't give Federal
funding to the people who aren't who are
who aren't here illegally I'm fine with
that if you're not here legally you
should not be receiving benefits in any
way California should not get a
congressional seat because of illegal
immigrants they let in and don't enforce
the laws against if the federal
government's if so so this is the big
problem the this is why I feel like the
country is on the verge of blowing up
collapsing whatever you want to call it
Texas has to abide by the votes of
California when it comes to the federal
government but California is breaking
the federal rules to strengthen itself
so imagine you you got a roommate and
your your roommate is taking your stuff
and selling it and then using that money
to pay your rent or whatever and you're
like yo you can't do this you're
stealing my stuff basically well you
know I pay more rent than you so I get
more say California is breaking the
rules bringing people in then arguing
they should get more say than everybody
else
why would Texas or Florida want to be a
part of a union that allows that
I know that the national divorce
question is huge right now the only the
thing that gives me pause about this and
I understand your question because it
seems like it makes it impossible to
work with each other but I I just want
to remind everybody of what the woke
Mantra was in 2020 right it's disrupt
and dismantle right that was the whole
thing and it seems to me that the left
has done a lot of disrupting and they're
leaving it to the right to dismantle a
little bit where it's like okay we've
disrupted all this stuff aren't you
super mad at California well then we
need a national divorce because what I
keep reminding people of is that you
know first of all the more you talk
about divorce the more likely it is to
happen uh that's if you've ever been in
marriage counseling or anything like
that but the other part of it is that it
the the only thing that's keeping the
global oligarchy from from taking over
completely I believe is the Constitution
of the United States and if you have a
disillusion if you have a divorce the
Constitution is gone I mean it is in
effect gone and so then we have a
serious problem because then we've
actually brought we've brought to the
left what the left wanted in the first
place because they disrupt and we
dismantled so I would just I would I
understand the sentiment and I know it's
difficult but we've been through worse
times right but in the constitution is
basically gone as it is because red
states don't do anything Republicans
don't do anything there has been a
growing contingent of people say the
Maga movement or whatever who have been
resisting The Establishment is is
freaking out and they've been freaking
out but you take a look at Mitch
McConnell who I love this he was asked
about nordstream who could have done it
he goes well it certainly wasn't us or
something like that it's like oh yeah
okay Russia blipped their own pipeline
no sane rational person who pays
attention to politics thinks that but
this is what they do this is what they
think of you and how they present quote
unquote facts so what is what does this
mean for us if we have if we if we have
a constitution or otherwise are they
infringing on our rights to free speech
yes every single day are they infringing
on a right keeping their arms yes
incessantly they even infringed on the
third amendment with the coped lockdowns
by mandating that people who are in the
U.S armed forces could not be evicted
that violence third don't even get me
started on the fourth amendment come on
unwarranted search and seizure the mass
spying programs Fifth Amendment dude
there are people who are locked up all
the time January 6 is a great example
the list goes on and on and on but do
you think that the left is the only ones
doing that I mean that's why I'm saying
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter so
the idea now is sit back and let
California cheat and break the law and
abuse people and and let Democrats do it
nationwide and Riot and burn down
buildings or
say no and get a national divorce I
think that we have there's I think that
a national divorce is a little too
extreme and I think that I've I made an
argument on Twitter that at this point I
think uh convention Estates is the is
the only legal means to get to have to
have a divorce it says to actually
dissolve uh with that because the thing
you were talking last night about
um the Civil War the thing about the
Civil War is they didn't have the the
states to call a convention so that it
was technically illegal right this for
the states to secede because they
couldn't actually make the amendment if
you call a article 5 convention you can
actually amend the Constitution it's not
going to be easy but it's a whole lot
easier you can't be living without
electricity because we had a civil war
and the infrastructure is just calling a
convention does not get you the
requisite votes for changing the
Constitution it simply brings people to
a room who then argue again and so you
can you can you can make amendments to
the Constitution which then have to be
voted on and ratified by the states but
independent but independent of DC yes
and then we don't have enough states to
even call a convention and if we did I
would say half of the red states are
going to go slow down there dab of craps
and then do nothing you're not wrong but
the uh but so what we have right now is
we are in a in an abusive relationship
where we're being pummeled and beaten in
the face and people are going but if but
if you leave him you'll be homeless and
I'm like I'd rather sleep under a bridge
the point the point is
you have to exhaust the legal means that
that are afforded to the population for
for any for any anything to be
legitimate you have to go through all
legal means First National divorce is
the statement
asking for a legal it is but again you
are you're enabling what I believe is
behind the disillusion of America or the
disillusion of us as a people you're
giving them exactly what they want
because I care what they want yeah well
that's not an argument I think it is an
argument because if you if you're
playing into what the plan is because
it'll be worse after you don't have the
protection of the Constitution albeit it
may be weakened I just I disagree states
have their own constitutions it's like
saying my significant other is
mercilessly beating me demanding I leave
the house but if I do leave I'll be
giving them exactly what they want it's
like or you leave and then you stop
getting beaten and then you'll be
responsible for yourself so I'm not
saying a national divorce is the
guaranteed absolute way to solve these
problems I'm just saying the argument
that we should sit here take the abuse
and then cross our fingers is also not
an answer but you also have you can
fight back through the legal means to
stop these things and you have more you
have more tools to be able to do that
within within the system that we have
within the Constitutional system that we
have lawsuits have just barely begun
right exactly lawsuits have just barely
begun this is the the the the naivety
okay California will do will not stop
these these cult members are hell-bent
on imposing everything about their
psychosis on the rest of the country and
the other side which is independent
conservative post-liberal or whatever
are saying please leave me alone but
please leave me alone doesn't stop
abusers from trying to destroy you and
harm your children and so we're at a
point now where that we've got Marjory
Taylor green and other people like
Michael malice and lucrakowski among
many others saying maybe a peaceful
divorce a national divorce and now you
have many conservatives coming out
saying no that's a bad idea because then
we lose this we lose that we lose this
and I'm like actually I think the cities
will collapse in two seconds without the
rural areas that prop them up these
people seem to think that National
divorce means state borders no no no
that's not what it means at all it
likely would mean if you look at the
secession movement in Oregon in Eastern
Oregon it would strip the rural Farmland
from the cities that are oppressing them
and the people in eastern Oregon are
trying to secede first and foremost just
from Portland basically so that they can
join Idaho and be working with a
community that more agrees with them
that's step one that's not even National
divorce and Portland says F you know
because the people who live in eastern
Portland are poorer but produce the food
and the resources the city needs to
survive you cut that off the city ceased
to exist in two seconds so if there was
a national divorce I'd imagine Los
Angeles New York Portland Chicago Etc
would crumble and people would panic and
it would be sheer chaos as they went to
farms and desperately begged you for
food now California as a state produces
a ton of food but the parts that produce
the food are all conservative so what
would happen if there was a national
divorce would the people in California
be like guess we're stuck with
California or would they be like the
borders are dissolving we're with that
but you also have to remember that the
people producing the food make their
money and they're living by selling the
food to the cities so if they're not
selling the food to the cities to the
people who eat it then they're not
making money either so it's within their
it's it's in their best interest to keep
them
of it I know I don't know it's leverage
I get it but it but it's also it's it's
leverage
the only why is it that the cities have
leverage over the people the workers why
is it that the guy who works at BuzzFeed
and writes articles about Brad Pitt's
junk is getting four times the income of
a dude who works the field picking crops
how does that make sense we as a society
value a dude who goes on the internet
and says Donald Trump is Hitler more
than a guy who grows the food we need to
eat that makes no sense and if there was
some kind of let me got to call it a
national divorce some kind of
restructuring and an assertion of the
leverage and the and the authority of
those who actually make this country
work then you would see cities collapse
overnight or desperate and that's that's
where language is really important here
because I think that you can do that
within the system that we have is that
if that is red states and their
Governors and and their legislatures
were to actually put their foot down
right and trust me I live in the reddest
state in America and I get very
frustrated with exactly what it is that
you're describing here where it's just
like oh you know oh will this do the
2030 plan and you know make a bunch of
money off of whatever when they when
they should be standing up to these
other states and you know filing a a
lawsuit like Texas did against
Pennsylvania when with the mail-in
voting and hopefully we could have a
supreme court that would actually take
up a case like that because it was
really important
Monopoly with people who are cheating
and and they keep going well I'll just
keep trying and eventually I'll win and
the people who are cheating death they
definitively believe they are justified
in doing what they do because they're
morally right so what we need is okay
before National divorce we need a real a
realignment of the leverage the one
simple thing is that the producers in
this country of which they're they're
they're they're growing increasingly
less to just outright say no to those
cities sorry we no longer Drive our
trucks and deliver to you
because you're destroying this country
see the problem is most people and and
the reason we're in this mess is because
most people will tell you I agree with
you but I will do nothing to bring risk
to myself Matt Strickland comes on this
show and talks about how his restaurant
was being targeted by ABC by the
government They seized all his booze
they shut him down and he refused to
back down anyone then he gets phone
calls from people saying what you did
was amazing we support you what can we
do to help and he said do the same thing
brother and then go oh no I would never
do that I will only stand back and hide
in the shadows as you assume all the
risks for yourself tell you to keep
doing it while I watch you get
steamrolled by the government and then
do nothing to support you because well
you know life's not that bad right well
and we see that kind of thing on the
internet all the time I mean just
right yeah exactly and I have two words
my Twitter account people were oh man
we're terrified to touch me because of
my Twitter clarify to touch me because
my Twitter No I know I think I've
experienced that and we probably all
have it nobody will come to your Aid
even if they know you're right because
they just don't want to be
you know mixed up in their drama right
yes they're cowards and that that's
really disappointing we did this skating
event in DC and I was warned by some
industry guys they were like hey man
like you shouldn't go to DC and do this
thing people are really mad it's gonna
be it's going to be a lot of heat and
it's you know we're worried and then I'm
like dude I live here I I live in the DC
area I go skate where I feel like
skating and you know what happened
nothing the locals skated got a few fist
bumps gave out a bunch of skateboards a
crowd was there we cheered we all skated
we filmed nobody said anything negative
these people live in the state of fear
over a boogeyman that doesn't exist yes
and they're scared to speak up because
you know what maybe the reason YouTube
allows a show like this is that us
talking about wokeness and the cult puts
it in the minds of people to be afraid
right that when we say people are afraid
because these things happen that
reinforces it I don't know man it's it's
it's frustrating that we get to the
point where Marjorie Taylor green says
National divorce and there are people
who are still just like no no no slow
down on their Democrats and I'm like
dude
if we were at the point where we know
for a fact that California is bringing
in non-citizens to fluff their numbers
and give themselves more Federal power
that is a very serious Act of corruption
that is destroying the union and Texas
knows it and Oklahoma knows it and
Nebraska knows it all of these red
States know it and they do nothing they
let California cheat and then just do
nothing
what are they supposed to do well uh I
think the federal government well I'll
put it this way at this point it seems
like the federal government is unwilling
to enforce these rules the Texas V
Pennsylvania lawsuit was a good start
but they need to start cutting off trade
and and it should be like sanctions the
idea that Texas allowed a man's child to
be taken to California for sex change
surgery or medication is insane why
would Texas allow that to happen imagine
if you lived in a state and a parent
said that they were going to bring a
child across state lines to kill them
for medical assistance and death and the
state went
that's fine it's like so there's no law
protecting life okay we got a problem
there Texas or any other state that
allows a person to cross across its
borders to commit crimes elsewhere then
we have no rule of law I mean imagine if
you you took a kid across state lines
the federal government agrees with what
this woman is doing to this kid and they
won't do anything about it
and no one else will okay you you could
say that we can't have a national
divorce but as far as I'm concerned when
you're at the point where Colorado says
No Limit abortions and Oklahoma says no
abortions at all and California says sex
change for kids and Texas says no but
the federal government is siding with
one side that's breaking the law there
is no government there is no United
States there is no Constitution it is
simply people holding on to an image or
a memory they once had wishing that it
was still true but it's not but then the
option is just force right the uh the
option is loss of confidence the option
is as a business don't trade with
California look at what the liberal
states do they bar their employees and
the government from going to Atlanta or
otherwise they they put restrictions on
companies doing business with other
countries I'm sorry other other states
uh other counties we'll recover it that
way but Republicans don't do the same
Mitch McConnell sits down and goes well
slow down
and people keep voting for him voting
for McCarthy and we get the same thing
over and over there's an economic reason
for that because you have like States
like Oklahoma on the whole do not have
the money in the income that California
does right I mean they don't have the
business they don't have Google I mean
they're starting to get it now Google's
starting to inject itself into red
states which I'm just like guys hey
don't don't be careful what you wish for
here you know um but they they don't
have the the large businesses you know
in Montana that they do in in California
and so they're in many ways dependent
upon that that 21st century income that
they see the world going towards and so
it it they feel like it's a little bit
they've got them over the barrel
California it's the fifth if it was a
country it would be the fifth largest
economy in the world right alone just
the state it apparently pulled in 3.63
trillion dollars in 2022 Gross Gross
State product
uh the largest in the United States the
largest economy of any state in the
United States so it's kind of like
asking a kid to stop eating the breast
milk of its mother like no it's like
California is our Western economy like
it is the the mouth of our entire Port
system essentially well so so start with
this charge California 3x taxes for
sending for for their goods going into
your state
say Okay California if you want to sell
your products in our state then you got
to pay a tariff you gotta you got to pay
a a state you know import fee yeah and
so then they just go well yeah we'll
just do more business with China you
know what I mean like have a nice day
you know and this idea that the right is
unwilling to boycott or unwilling to say
no they're unwilling to forego their
luxuries then then lose by all means
then lose if you would prefer to have
peaceful slavery by all means don't let
me stand in your way however if you
would like to assess the situation and
realize that with with freedom comes
risk and responsibility well then the
choice is yours if you want to go out
and if so so for us for instance we
decided we want to get away from the
cities and we come to West Virginia and
there there are risks that come with
leaving a city we can't get internet new
place where we're at these are
challenges it's ridiculously expensive
internet costs several thousand dollars
per month out here costs 90 bucks in the
city but I would rather spend that money
than live in these areas supporting what
they're doing
so
for a lot of people they choose peaceful
slavery over dangerous freedom and you
know what
that's part of Freedom too by all means
be be that live that life that's not for
me you know I'd rather give the middle
finger and say I'm not going to support
your machine now don't get me wrong
there are varying degrees to which we
have to coexist and and be strategic I'm
not saying it is simply put that we all
just stop watching Disney my position on
this has always been I don't expect the
average person to just boycott Disney
outright not watch anything from Disney
ever again because that's unreasonable
the average person but we have to build
the cultural infrastructure to shift
them away from it and make things that
make them say I'd rather watch this
instead Yellowstone's a great show yes
some people have called it woke which
makes no sense to me the show is very
anti-woke support shows like this which
has a bit of nuance in it and is in my
opinion relatively anti-woke it's got
some good woke moments that I think are
fine but it's mostly like there's a
scene where the one there's an
environmentalist and she's insulting the
family and a character says I don't know
a lot about about this environmental
stuff but I'll tell you this you don't
change anyone's Mind by insulting them
and their family in their own home and
I'm like here here I like that stuff but
that's that's a kind of like what I was
saying earlier is that we're now just
labeling people so much if there's a
woke moment and a show the show is woke
right if there's an unwoke moment in a
show the show is on woke right and then
they'll just bifurcates us into this
point where it's like okay everybody
says that we want to you know have a
parallel economy I get that I think that
makes sense where you have places to go
and that's that's the free market right
but when we start pejorativeizing or
demonizing these shows like like because
I love that show right I hate the woke
parts of it and I just point that out to
people I use that to say look hey this
is what's actually I believe is wrong
about this and I use that as a teaching
moment then enjoy the rest of the show
right and it seems that we're unwilling
to do that because there is Market
influence that says well I'm going to
create the unwoke version of the show
you know and then and then you see that
in the clicks and the influencer it says
go watch this one when we could also
around the same show and enjoy it we are
seeing some positive moves West Virginia
for instance Florida getting rid of the
SG
the state saying outright we don't do
business this way we need more of this
we need more red states to outright ban
companies that break the law ESG is
illegal so you're simply put you're
looking for states to States State
legislatures and State uh Governors to
step up and say okay we're going to
that's that's one element that's Vivek
rava Swami's platform yeah that is it is
platform the other element is that we as
individuals have to be conscious about
the products we buy how about this
here's a start when you go to the
grocery store if you see something take
a look at where it's packaged and
produced it says California put it back
don't touch it don't buy it ever again
if you see something that's coming from
a red State there you go there's the
product you buy better yet Google search
the company are they doing ESG don't buy
their garbage because I don't expect you
to stop going to a grocery store I don't
expect you to stop buying whipped cream
and hoes and Ding Dongs just buy the
cupcakes that are coming from people who
agree with you so download Public Square
the app that shows you businesses that
agree with American values that's phase
one creating a pair parallel economy can
prevent the need for some kind of
national divorce if as a culture we
shift back into the things we value but
having a parallel economy if you don't
have a unifying Spirit or a unifying
message that connects you as a as a
country will actually I think spur a
national divorce you know and it may
lead to that and I say I'm not saying
that we shouldn't do it I think you if
you want to you spend your money where
you want to spend your money right and
if in and people creating options of
that within the market absolutely do
that but let's make let's make a movie
in music studio in West Virginia yeah
and we'll start producing film I mean
look the daily wire started making
movies and uh they need to invest as
much as they can in that space it's very
very hard but it is very hard because
partly because of the ESG of it all
because you can't get you can't get good
loan rates if you don't have a good ESG
score but you know
that's currently in in like that's at
the Active situation now it is right it
is the act because if if you don't agree
with these they give you loan rates yes
upon your ESG score Rama Swami is
talking about a lot it's that and where
he was the first one to come out I I'm
really glad that he's in the race we
talked about Trump and I I read vivek's
book woke Inc go out and read that book
because it really pieces it all together
but he he pieces all of this uh together
and shows you exactly how these
companies have injected themselves into
government right and and this whole
mechanism is using to break down the
American Spirit yeah it's to to stop us
from seeing what we do have in common by
constantly throwing in front of our face
the politics of division you know and so
I'm glad he's running I I think Trump
did a great thing here but I know we're
we're kind of off that top I think so
left in the when people say left right
red blue that that is the division that
is the path to destruction like that's
uh Mao zeitung he was like let's talk
about the rightists he created a group
of of society that was on the right and
that was the best way to divide people
so I I don't like thinking of terms of
like you've got to be in a camp because
as soon as you think that way you're
building a reality that way but
everything in our Market forces right
now is pushing us towards that Direction
that's what I notice people are choosing
I don't think it's a direction though
that's the thing it's like an it's like
a system that's calculating and wants a
certain output I wanna I wanna throw an
idea out do you guys really think that
it is left versus right or do you feel
like the left is really Consolidated and
it's the left versus everyone that
doesn't line up with the list it's like
a technocratic versus everyone it's a
uniparty situation because you have a
lot of Republicans out there that
pretend to be Republicans when it's
convenient for them and everything
they're doing under the radar is Right
aligned with what the left wants whether
you're talking about the 2030
environmental uh plan that that Biden
has and and the Democrats have had for a
long time you see red State Republicans
buying into this on a regular basis this
while they go out and say well you know
I we banned abortion so you know that's
good but we're leading the state down
the same thing the same situation that
made California California today you
know and that's really frustrating in a
red state so I don't think of them as
like red I mean I I understand the idea
of being able to talk about things in
binary like you're the there I'm here
okay fine but we are one in the eyes of
God all right uh all right so I but I
think that sometimes I wonder if if my
own peer group has been brainwashed in
the last seven years to think in terms
of division and that just acknowledging
the division is the division I I
disagree I don't care what you call it
you call it the cult call it the left
call it the woke call it whatever
there's a group of people that are a
cult and that's all that matters I see
the world economic Forum being involved
in it trying to manipulate it as a
technocrats I I see that call for sure
it's one of us attacking the United
States but ignoring China and India it's
ignoring East Palestine
showing up to Ohio and saying this is
what we're talking no they don't care at
all it's people like AOC making up fake
problems and lying about what happened
in the capital it's that video of the
dude with the earpiece pulling people
into the capital did you see this video
I've heard about it there's a video of a
man with an earpiece and he's grabbing
people and throwing them into the
building and a woman's yelling at him
saying you're why are you pulling us in
here you're forcing Us in here and it's
going to earpiece did you see the video
today that came out uh with the police
officer saying he was screaming they set
us up I mean standing right outside the
capitol they set us up here we've been
locked up want to release it exactly I
mean and
uh the fact that that hasn't made
national news is an outrage right I
imagine Tucker Carlson will be handling
that he should somebody is that
available to watch right now on Twitter
it's on Twitter yeah the issue is you
have a cult the cult doesn't care the
country is split between the cult and
everybody else and everybody else
includes traditional liberals yeah who
consider himself disaffected
Libertarians conservatives and even
anti-war leftists who are economically
left but don't adhere to the estate so
how do we unify that group of people to
avoid the need for a national divorce
because if we if we if you want to call
it the silent majority or just people
that don't think they have anything in
common majority of the Biden voters
Trump supporters think they're the
silent majority but they're not they're
the they're the active paying attention
people most people are not paying
attention they are silent because they
don't care they don't want to be
involved see I feel like that that that
uh
Bill Maher video about the that he put
out recently about uh where he likened
the woke to maoist and the cultural
revolution yes uh in China and
acknowledge that there is a cultural
revolution going on here I think that
that is the kind of
impactful video from the kind of person
that can actually make the average
Normie realize what's going on because
your average person
I think your average person still thinks
that communism is bad generally they
don't I don't I think that but they
don't know what communism is when they
hear socialism they think Medicare for
all when they hear communism they think
you know Mao Zedong and Stalin I think
that's generally the way that that
people react and I think that if people
can if you can make get people to make
the connection between woke uh kids at
colleges screaming in their Prof in
their professors faces with the Red
Guard screaming in the faces of the
Chinese professors if they could if you
can make that connection that will do
significant damage to the uh to the to
the to the woke agenda or whatever you
want if you've not listened to James
Lindsay on this subject you need to go
do it because you're just screaming
about James yeah me too brother and then
it he has been talking about Mal and the
cultural revolution for three or four
years him and Michael uh O'Fallon over
at Sovereign Nations have been talking
about about this for a long time and I'm
glad that Bill Maher finally picked it
up but it's going to take more people
like that to to highlight the the exact
same process that happened in China in
the 60s and 70s is happening now and if
we can show them the Evergreen like with
Brett Wayne's Brett Weinstein you're the
Evergreen video that opened up my eyes
I'm like holy crap you know so we need
more Bill Mars to who actually have some
of the ears and the eyes of the left to
bring on James Lindsay to bring on these
people that really know this subject you
can show it this is this is why I have
been harping on building culture more
than anything else yeah and it's very
very difficult but that's the path
forward when I had these industry guys
in skateboarding tell me oh you better
watch out if you do skateboarding bad
things are going to happen nothing bad
happened they need to maintain the fear
that if we enter Cultural spaces we will
be physically harmed so that we don't
because when we do uh oh all of a sudden
young people are looking up to us and
they're like hey that's really cool I
want to do that too so the biggest
threat to the welcome machine is all of
all of us and everyone listening making
culture performing shows go to a venue
write a song called fjb and then sing
the song on stage at a venue and just be
bold with it and be like that's how I
think it is what it is write a whole
record called victim of the new disease
about communism can I can I just say
something about this because I I'm I've
been involved in the Arts my whole live
music teacher all of that the the
organized music education in this
country has been completely taken over
and what people don't understand is that
music is the most effective form of
propaganda that you can have it's and I
use this Loosely but you have people
that sing in church together for a
reason because when you're all singing
for the same message they've actually
done they've tested this your heartbeat
starts to beat at the same time
literally because you're singing in the
same rhythm with the same sounds with
the same people I think it's one of the
main reasons they wanted to shut down
churches during covet because you know
where two or three are gathered in my
name there I am also was it's from the
Bible but the Arts in this Society have
been completely taken and over and when
you're talking about the American choral
Directors Association or the American
band director's Association that their
whole job is to knit together teachers
from across the country in public and
private schools alike and now they're
unifying behind this woke message behind
this maoist version of the way that they
want Society to be and it's very scary
so I would encourage Republicans if
you're listening at all or conservatives
Libertarians classical liberals let's
get involved in organized Arts uh in in
the school level I think it could be
very effective in helping us turn back
the the woke monster that we're seeing
prevailing over our country I also want
to acknowledge the danger of Cults in
general like within my own ranks within
the people like right now I identify
with a lot of people that consider
themselves Christians they're the go to
Christian Church in some way and I'm
looking at Joel Osteen Osteen is that he
pronounce his name you know this guy's
mega church uh Pastor or preacher he
made like 54 million dollars last year
don't get me started on that my father
my parents came out of that situation
where it was the name it claim it you
know Word of Faith movement and they are
Crooks I mean they're Crooks because my
father had nothing my mother had nothing
and they would give over their last and
not to their local church that could
help them but they would hand it over to
Kenneth Copeland or Joel Osteen or
whomever and say well I've done my part
and the Lord's gonna give me a new car
and they died with nothing
they died with absolutely nothing at a
young age because they were putting
their faith into something that was just
you know a mile wide and an inch deep
and so I I they're Crooks I I I'm a
Christian but I have something very
visceral against people like that that
that take advantage of poor people
through their faith I think it's it's
what led us into the woke movement as we
know it today is that kind of belief
part of what erupt made Jesus I rate as
well from the stories is the people
trying to profit off of absolutely the
message I I think that and it's taxed at
free it's tax free because it's a
religion Joel can take their money and
he doesn't have to pay taxes on it it's
complete I mean that is what an abuse of
and they walk into his church expecting
to get something of depth and what they
get is a nice you know frou-frou oh I
feel good as I leave kind of a
television Church show and they get
nothing of depth from the Christian
faith in that and it has done I think
it's done as much as anything the left
has done to to put people down the disc
affected road with Christian values with
some of the values that our country was
founded on that actually helped keep us
strong so I'm right with you on that I I
have nothing good to say about the
osteins but yeah that brings a lot of
people from if you want to call it the
left to the right to the reason is when
you when people are willing to
acknowledge the flaws in their own faith
that the business that has erupted
around their faith that's like people
that aren't even involved like wow that
maybe this person is actually a cogent I
think this is a simple distinction
between Christianity for instance and
wokism in terms of ideology ideology
one seeks with Christianity there's
something Beyond you as a human being
and Beyond everybody with wokeness your
God it's you you are old things the
world must change for you it's it's yin
yang almost it's the the belief that
there is something greater than me and
so it's not about me and then there's
the woke side where it's I'm owed and I
deserve well any again go listen to
James lisney what he's talking about
gnosticism right it's a hermetic it
grabs a hold of a faith whether it's
Christianity Islam it doesn't matter
what it is and it infests it to a
certain extent and turns it the
doctrines and everything towards what
its political motive is and so it is and
where's your ideology like a skin
exactly and so go go listen to James
Lindsay and what he's talking about
gnosticism because what you're
describing there is exactly what he's
talking that's the malthusian I I like
that I actually identify with that kind
of thing like I am God there is a God
Beyond me and I am God together it's we
make God that Jesus was God yet there
was God but you're not Jesus
no yeah it is different it's very much
the same God flows through us it
animates our bodies so we are part of it
so you can say looking at yourself as
somebody who can who can be on on the
plane as God then you have nothing
Beyond yourself to search for and
therefore the only thing that matters is
what you care about in the moment and
that's that's what James has been
talking about a lot is that if you see
yourself as a version of God or is it on
equal part with God then you're
automatically just going to completely
Divorce Yourself from anything natural
in the world you're going to say well if
I feel like a girl I am a girl right and
if my son says he feels like a girl then
he is a girl and I'm gonna make him into
one that's what it turns into if you see
yourself as that level of of deity yeah
it doesn't end there it doesn't end with
I'm God and therefore I control react
it's it's I am God and God is I am there
it's both uh if you can't maintain both
thoughts at the same time you're doomed
to chaos us you've got to understand
that you're part of it but the minute
you start thinking yourself as God in
any form then you've lost the plot I
think because there there's a God and
then there's you would you say that to
Jesus Christ absolutely
Jesus Christ I believe was a different
uh part of the situation right I mean he
was he was divinely inspired he was here
for a purpose and then he left right he
died on the cross for our sins and then
he rose again and then he said this is
this is the faith that you need to be
saved in the afterlife and Beyond but he
didn't say hey Ian you can be just like
me you're you're the only begotten Son
of God too no he said you are one with
me but you are not me right you must
live towards a goal you're never going
to be perfect right but you striving for
Perfection is what makes life worth
living making the mistakes and then
repenting and then doing better the next
time is what makes life worth living but
just seeing that no matter what I do
uh is right because I'm God that's a
completely different thing we're going
to go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends and head
over to timcast.com become a member
because once we wrap up this show around
10 p.m we will kick off the live
uncensored members only portion of the
show after that show wraps the live just
the recording remains on the website to
be watched at your leisure at any time
and will be part of a massive library of
existing content the only difference
between what we used to do what we're
doing now is that you can watch as we
record so before we record it then
upload it now we'll just live stream it
and then it's boom there forever for you
to watch so hang out live you can chat
we're setting up a Discord so that you
can not only chat for the members only
live show but even call in we can do a
voice Channel where you can actually
talk to the people on the show
it'll be a lot of fun and like with
radio I imagine we're gonna be telling a
lot of people you got to turn the turn
the computer down we're getting Echo
we're getting Echo all right hillbillary
Clinton says animals and crops are dying
in East Palestine and it's due to the
government releasing chemicals and
trying to be covert about it now will
you finally say MK Naomi
I don't know what does that mean
I don't know that Naomi wolf hey Naomi
no idea say it say it say her name I did
all right Smoking Man Vibe says I bet
Biden knows the Cat Knows the Cavs but
asking about Ohio and he knows nothing
he is such a liar isn't that right Ian
oh I'm I'm sorry I was just reading
about MK Naomi dude it's a CIA research
program have you heard of this chemical
warfare program oh 50s to the 70s I'm
sorry what was that last Super Chat was
that directed to me it says I bet Biden
knows the Cavs but asking about Ohio he
knows nothing he's such a liar isn't
that right Ian yeah well he loves Ohio
but don't ask him about it because he'll
tell you he doesn't know anything about
Ohio
not a lie though on second thought says
which is harder for Joe elected Biden
stairs or a complete sentence answers
please yes and then a bogus emoji
[Music]
says he had balloons tied to his gun and
Biden shot the balloons with missiles
from an F-22 that explains it the
balloon story was because it was
carrying the uh the weapon there
well non-bizzle AKA James says I watch
in the am at work gets me through the
toughest part of my day as a letter
carrier I just wanted to say I wore my
ssj trump shirt today before I knew
Trump was going to Ohio awesome the
Super Saiyan Trump shirt we made
I went to an AI and I was like Donald
Trump going Super Saiyan and it's Trump
yelling ah his hair is
very nice
all right
Oka mihoro Okami horo says do everyone
in actual service by covering where the
individual is shot this fact matters a
great deal in the chest that's right
yeah
copper Lobo says Norfolk Southern
Railroad is owned by Vanguard BlackRock
and JP Morgan yeah but like to be fair
they own everything so that's true
Brandon hampson says Tim in regards to
the unalive case you're missing the
obvious the guy shot himself with a
ghost gun
red wing blackbird says did Kurt Cobain
have connections to the clintons yeah
that explains it
yeah yes
Bobcat says Gary Webb or Danny casellaro
granted most journalists who investigate
the CIA mob doj trinary tend to commit
suicide in impossible ways fairly often
and they do because the alphabet
agencies want you to know
that they can say whatever they want and
make it obvious it's a warning that's
right
all right
TNT for you says Tim come on man the 500
million dollars isn't coming from our
tax money it's just being printed for
future generations to pay for
technically it's also just being
extracted from your buying power from
your savings so when they print money
and then give it to Ukraine and they buy
stuff with it
you work hard you put money in the bank
the government then just fabricates
money to give to someone else they don't
work hard they spend it on war but that
money gets spent back in the United
States causing inflation and your
ability to buy things for your hard work
goes down is an invisible tax where
they're extracting your hard work and
you don't see it happening that was the
trick one day some dude said listen if
we go to all the people and tell them to
give us a dollar you know they're going
to get really angry if we just make the
dollars we extract from their labor
because their debt is gear is the
guarantee for this money meaning the
fact that you're willing to accept these
dolls in the first place means the money
has value to somebody else
and then the more we flood the market
the more we extract from your buying
power based on your labor so you're
giving your money away but you don't see
it happening
and that's how modern monetary policy
works well we got oh we just ran into
the table you got a bogus what's he
doing he was sleeping you woke him up
well you gotta close the door you're
doing good yeah he looks great where'd
he go yeah he's down here
he's just standing there doing Boca
stuff we're gonna need some Focus emojis
in the check you want to get them on the
table get it going
you got him Mr bocus wanna bring him up
okay no he's not having it yeah
all right
Lord Lucas Ward says where is the bloody
UFO in with a one roll oh there's Mr
Wilkins wow he's looking real good yeah
he's he's been dancing hopefully those
stem cells have been I brought him on
last Thursday I think it was shortly
after he got in an ejection so he was
exhausted that day but this is I mean he
just woke up
he's looking all right well I was
listening I was listening to the Daily
wire morning cast on the UFO situation
and they were saying that they had an
explanation for all of these supposed
UFOs that the Pentagon was you know
calling UFOs at the point you know it
was one was from like a bottle cap
company like where they were just
putting up a balloon or something like
that but they had an explanation and
none of them had to do with you know
aliens or anything like that but they
were they were sure enough very cryptic
in the moment while all this stuff in
East Palestine was going on to make you
think oh it could have been a UFO we got
all the focus emojis in the chat they
love you Buckle there he is he's just
doing a good sitting there doing Boca
stuff come here he's ruling the table
right now we were we were told he'd be
dead in a week wow yeah and then we got
him medicine hormone treatment fluid
injections it was very expensive and now
he's getting stem cells and he seems to
be uh he's getting a little thicker he
was really gaunt he was fading and now
he seems to be coming back I think in
about a half a pound half a kilogram
half a pound he was a fourth of a pound
the first week then .02 kilograms the
second week wow measured him lately I
think the stem cells might be working I
think the hormones in the fluid probably
helped one of the reasons for the weight
loss may have been the anemia
so you know he he's he we don't know how
much longer he'll have even if he is his
treatment is working with the stem cells
maybe what uh give him a few more years
he's a long cat yeah yeah dude yeah
legit all right
Austin Brown says podcast of the Lotus
Eaters has been showing the absurdity of
the UK situation a million plus a year
coming into a country the size of New
York State
you know
David Toronto says so Tim we should
leave them in Florida Texas Etc no my
point was Texas should have the right to
deport people that's it's that simple
Texas and Florida should Deport them
back to their home countries there you
go yeah how you going how's it going Mr
bocus what are you doing
what is preventing them from just doing
like California does and ignoring the
federal law on it letting them in yeah
because yeah I mean the issue with
deporting is that it's an issue for
another country yeah Texas can't talk
with I think you got to put a little bit
more water in there
no he's got it oh yeah look he's thirsty
does he is he still drinking a lot of
water like crazy no because that was
that that was a sign that his kidneys
were failing he kept drinking water I
think the new food has offered him
better hydration when he was even with
the new food he was drinking water like
crazy I think it's the stem cells and
he's still getting fluid every other day
shout out to Kim I mean it's this is a
it's a it takes a tribe to raise a young
one like this Cara's been doing a
fantastic job with him too he absolutely
loves her all right Pat Meadow says did
Biden observe Ash Wednesday yes he did
yes he did yeah he had the uh the ash on
his forehead I thought it was a bruise
from him falling down but it was the ash
falling off yeah all falling off sorry
sorry Biden's ashes were made of burnt
uh cremated babies he made an abortion
aborted babies
Brado Jacko says open borders cannot
work with a welfare state election
corruption and zero social cohesion with
no understanding of American civics or
the Constitution agreed he's really
jamming his face in there I think he
needs more water more yeah
all right get it bucko
oh that looks good
oh he's there now he's a thirsty friend
yeah there you go Matt McCartney says
the Constitution does not apply to
anyone in the country a tourist or
non-resident immigrant can't buy a gun
here under any legal circumstances the
Constitution absolutely 100 does apply
to anyone in the country the fact that
they don't let people buy guns means
they're infringing on your rights but it
does there have been numerous Supreme
Court cases about the Fourth Amendment
and the First Amendment and basically
all the Amendments the Constitution
applies to everybody
it just means that uh
at this point they're infringing on
almost every element of the Constitution
the Constitution is a is a list of no's
for the government it doesn't tell the
people that they're not allowed to do
stuff exactly so
all right Ryan Ellis says Cali will
never turn red I deliver medication to
halfway homes and dementia hospitals
they let those people vote guess who
they vote for yeah California was read
up until what like 1988 was the last
time it voted for a republican please
this is George H.W bush yep but there
there's a systemic method that they use
to turn it what it is today and the
scary part about that is I see the same
thing happening in Oklahoma right now
what is it where where you have it
starts in the universities where you
have this in Oklahoma they have what's
at OU they have What's called the
Strategic research verticals where you
have uh the the university with a with a
plan to build public-private
Partnerships beyond the walls of the
university to create or to push a an
agenda that really lines up almost Point
by point with the wef uh and right now
it's all around ESG and what they do is
they they they they start implementing
program grams like for example in
Oklahoma they're doing Criminal Justice
Reform well there are some good parts
about that but what the left sees is
wait a minute now there's a red State we
can go to right that's cheaper to live
and and import a bunch of Californians
from California into Oklahoma and all of
a sudden you just start turning the
state blue and that and then you just
start giving more and more people more
subsidies more uh government assistance
and over time over 30 years you end up
having California and that's kind of
what happened to you Chris rufo covered
this before he started covering CRT
about how there was kind of a flag that
they threw up saying hey look homeless
people come here right what they did in
San Francisco what they did in La we're
going to build you low-cost housing
almost nobody lives in that low cost
housing it's still sitting there right
and lots of people made money off of
building it but all the homeless came
there right and and not they they get
you know free food they get free cell
phones they get all these other
government assistance and they vote
because people go out and hand on the
ballot and then grab it and bring it in
and turn it in and that's what you're
starting to see little by slowly
especially like in the college towns in
Oklahoma and it's designed to spread out
and I've been trying to warn people
their hair guys all of these things that
sound really good that weaponize your
empathy that you know this is to help
people isn't always exactly what it
seems so we should watch it yeah you all
should watch Yellowstone yes because
some people are like don't spoil the
show don't spoil the show okay I won't
spoil the show but a lot of this stuff
plays a role in the show the simple
version is you've got people who are
from Montana which there's you know they
are the the joke is no one's from
Montana and then you have people from
New York and California who are liberal
elites with lots of money who use it as
a playground and there's conflict well
and in Oklahoma they just brought in
Google and gave them charge over
collecting data for the state you know
with with chrome pads and things like
that so it's it's a hairy scheme because
you get a lot of money you get a lot of
that tide that raises All Ships but the
time side seems to be really like
communist red normies get out says look
at the liberal states that get blasted
by the Supreme Court for violating the
Constitution and their two-way laws they
just change the law slightly and reapply
it and rinse and repeat that's right
when they shut the churches down and the
courts I think it was a court in New
York said hey you can't do that they
went okay I'll just issue a new
executive order doing the exact same
thing and then you'll have to sue me for
that too Phil's uh Mr is is hanging out
with Mr bocus over there I'm popular Mr
Focus
Mr Bogus is enjoying himself
all right where we got
Le parti says Convention of states to
throw California out yes a Convention of
states where this what is it what about
Amendment 28 California is no longer a
member State of the Union by
someone was saying that's better than a
full National divorce it might have been
Thomas Massey we had a politician on and
I was asking about National or uh not
National Force but uh Convention of
States because I keep thinking like
that's a solution that's a way forward
and I was warned he warned me that it
could be weaponized absolutely it needs
to be now I don't know the the details
you can follow at cos project on Twitter
and they have all the Deets about the
progress of uh of the effort for a
convention
um it has to be limited in scope and the
delegates have to the delegates from the
several states have to abide by that so
if something is brought up that is
outside of the scope agreed upon
everyone has to get up and leave and or
something to that effect there are there
are ways to put guard rails on it I'm
not the expert that can tell you the
details about it but uh but yes it is
definitely I mean it's an extreme
measure we have you know it's a even to
amend the Constitution is actually
fairly extreme because the amendment
process is intentionally rigorous it's
not supposed to be easy to do these
things because we're supposed we have
states that have the have the capacity
and the the they're empowered to pass
laws for the several States each each
state can make basically whatever law
they want so
to make an amendment to the Constitution
is supposed to be a big deal the fact
that people say oh you know we should
just do this or just do that the federal
government should do that that was that
all this stuff is outside of the federal
government's initial Charter like the
things that the federal government is is
empowered to do are listed in the
Constitution the things that the federal
government is specifically prevented
from doing are listed in the Bill of
Rights and then any changes are in the
in the Amendments that follow the the
Bill of Rights and they're supposed to
be hard because of the way that our our
government is supposed to protect
Administration state has taken advantage
of that absolutely because absolutely
that's a you know
um there's
said that he wants to have an eight-year
term for people in the administrative
State you know that if you serve eight
years you're done I like it right
for politicians is is not as attractive
to me as term limits on bureaucracy
exactly that's that you should not be
able to work in a three-letter
unconstitutional
um uh apparatus for that long because
you will amass power just by being there
for that long yeah and so I really like
that idea I think that every I think I
think that's the direction we should go
I had not heard that but that is that
that is to me seems like a far better
idea than the idea that you get rid of
politicians every you know well I think
you should get rid of them both I mean I
think you should have term limits across
the board but you shouldn't be allowed
to camp in the CIA the FBI the IRS for
all of these years and a mass power and
push your political agenda under the
radar there should be an apparatus where
the president I mean the president can't
even fire a lot of these people which is
ridiculous that's ridiculous you know
what I mean but at the very least let's
have a constitutional member or a law or
statutory law that says your ears are up
you find a new job you know what I mean
all right disobey says the FED offered
all of the state several million to
expand red flag laws Kansas was offered
2.6 million I wonder if this is part of
Biden's plan to help with the spill
oh interesting yeah I can see that they
would want some sort of like red flag
thing they're like you we give for you
you give for us but see they're in a
state of disaster right now so that
should be a perfect opportunity for them
to take advantage crazy crazy that's
like yeah
all right Merrick Miller says don't eat
any what Chef want what chefs want
products in Colorado they are ordering
employees to perform illegal and
unethical policies and procedures that
are a threat to Public Health
interesting not familiar with that
hillbillary Clinton says but Biden says
you can't have weapons like us planes
and nukes are what people would need in
a civil war otherwise you would be
conquered I guess I'm paraphrasing but
it's close yeah and uh maybe he has an
answer for I don't know Vietnam or
Afghanistan
yeah because the reality is a an F-22
can't occupy a street corner a lot of
dudes named Mohammed in Afghanistan are
like yo I think you're wrong man yeah
and now they have all of the American
Equipment thanks for the night vision
yeah
Hillary Clinton says again how much do I
have to donate to your machine for you
to notice me which machine what are you
talking about I notice you we see you
that's right hillbillary I like the name
too Hillbillies and Val 90 says Ian
needs six more Chaos Emeralds to go
supersonic okay
okay I've got I've got emeralds
downstairs you know what I will bring an
emerald up tomorrow that's a good one I
always thought it was funny that in
Dragon Ball Z the like the the brown
eyed black-haired dude when he became
super powerful super he turned blonde
and he got blue eyes racist no no for
real like what was up with that and then
Sonic was the same way when Sonic went
Super Sonic he would turn gold and it's
like okay gold I guess but like Goku and
Dragon Ball Z is like I'm gonna become
really powerful ah and then his hair
turns blonde and his eyes turned blue
I'm like something weird about that just
like Aryan Nations yeah somewhere so I'm
weird about that huh they all do it
Naruto the Naruto is from Japan right
yeah uh it's leftovers from the war but
Naruto's not Dragon Ball Z they don't go
Super Saiyan in there okay and Naruto he
just like the nine-tailed fox Spirit
those Dragon Ball Z Dragon Ball Z is
Japan yeah yeah okay and and the funny
thing is Anime in Japan is like
man I I can't remember what neighborhood
I was in but they have like big Bill
Billboards and art of Goku and lupon III
and other characters that have been
around since the 70s or 80s to them
their cartoon characters are like movie
stars almost but I guess it's also kind
of like Mickey Mouse or Donald Duck the
crazy thing though is in America our
famous cartoon characters are you know
like what what is Mickey Mouse famous
for doing like driving a steamboat or
something yeah and then and then Donald
Duck complains about a lot of stuff I
guess their cartoon characters are
famous for you know like flying like
saving planets and you know doing
martial arts or I guess loop on the
third was a was a thief
you know I don't yeah well our more
modern cartoons like X-Men and things
like that but I guess they were yeah but
uh we we we have Mickey Mouse everywhere
yeah that's true they have Goku
everywhere yeah Goku is like flying
around beating people up you know he's a
good guy he's not a bad guy you know
he's beating up the bad guys but Mickey
Mouse didn't do anything like that
Mickey Mouse is going oh whatever that's
all about Japan's so awesome yeah it's a
cool place have you been there you know
they have like they have upstairs good
they have whack-off stores yeah they do
we do it in the store yeah you go in the
store and then they have like a variety
of objects and towels and you go into a
room and it's like the weirdest thing
I've ever seen but it's like a normal
thing in Japan so it reminds me of
Idiocracy where do you get a latte yeah
right you you don't even understand what
like Japan they're freaky freaky Diggy
man it's weird yeah I wasn't I was in
Japan in 2011 at the earthquake whoa oh
wow yeah yeah I was on CNN I talked to
uh they interviewed me and stuff yeah
what yeah
all right bucko's had enough for the
night I'm gonna say Goodbye Mr belkus
and monster bocus is off oh sorry buddy
you know I've never been an earthquake
but I was in in the Deep South uh in
about an hour from New Orleans during
Katrina so yeah it was rough it was
rough
all right let's see we got
audio some uh audio
somatic says Hey I just uh I saw Jordan
B Peterson and Everett Washington on the
19th he announced a new group he is
helping to put together that's going to
combat the wef look into it please I
think we've talked about it but he wants
to do it in London
it's like why London I don't know it
doesn't seem like a bad place to do it
it does you know like Charlestown West
Virginia seems like a good place to do
it and I'm only half kidding it would be
very convenient for me if you did it
here but uh you've also just got West
Virginia it's the second most Maga
country amaga state in the country
that seems to make more sense what's the
first Florida
uh no it's a Oklahoma it's got to be
close no I think it's Wyoming Wyoming
was the most Trump supporting State yeah
uh Tyler price says Naruto is also
blonde hair and blue eyed LMAO that is
true Naruto is blonde with blue eyes and
then I guess the Elric Brothers had like
reddish eyes yeah they were blonde
though and their dad's name was
hohenheim so literally it was like a
German Germanic name it's so weird I
never understood that I'm like why are
Japanese people making all these shows
about and then you get Attack on Titan
and like it's all German literally yeah
the buildings and everything yeah yeah
it's it's kind of weird you know we're
trying to tell us something I don't know
I don't know
maybe Caleb genre says North Dakota
pumps a million barrels of oil a day or
used to why does North Dakota only get
one house seat we're an energy
Powerhouse plus we grow food well it's
called Leverage yeah it's probably
leverage population that's why
the Badlands
because reason says I'm not suggesting
anyone is famous however if you were and
some people on the show are how do you
stay humble for no reason
well Phil how do you stay humble
uh I try not to I try not to think of
myself as as different from anyone else
I mean I I'm very much a normal dude I
do normal dudes things like I don't do
like rock star things really I mean I
don't drink I don't blow lines I don't
you know I'm not into into meth
this used to be like a crazy rock star I
used to drink too much
um actually Matt this month is five
years it was five years on uh um
congratulations February 14th as I had
my last sip of booze
um but yeah I I quit drinking because
drinking it didn't do anything positive
for me anymore there was a i there are
so many reasons I stopped drinking I
can't even begin to get into them there
was literally nothing good that came
from drinking and more bad things than I
could ever list off but I can imagine
beating something like that or stopping
something like that it does help keep
you humble because you saw yourself in
the worst possible yeah I mean yeah like
falling down in a face flat and a gutter
that'll that'll help you oh yeah I mean
I tell you what that there is there is
nothing nothing that humbles you more
than waking up and being like Oh God I
did say it so uh someone someone chatted
I don't know if there's a Super Chat
someone chatted Edward Elric had blue
eyes uh yes it's super 503 dank says the
Albert Brothers both had blue eyes which
is weird since you know they're dead no
they don't uh the Albert Brothers have
yellowish hazel eyes I guess you'd call
it yeah I I you know
yeah I but you know just whatever I'm
being pedantic I'm colorblind so I'm
really triggered by all this what's up
Japanese people really like this concept
of when you become powerful you get
blonde hair and blue eyes that's all I'm
saying I don't know why I don't know why
what was that all about you know nervous
Dalton says disavow Dawn says do you
think the military majority Republicans
are willing to fight in a war Biden has
made a point to happen I think U.S
military folk will want will uh will get
out draft time
yes perhaps I don't know though it's a
hell no for me bro I don't think that
the uh Steve days just the other night
said absolutely not I think Steve day
said it best I haven't heard someone
speak out against a war like that and
since like Clips with dudes I just had
my first daughter my first child and I
can't imagine I I I'm right there with
him you know I'm not sending especially
our daughters I mean come on there's no
way I'm sending anybody to fight and die
over there I think I think that the
Biden Administration intends or would
intend on ukrainians doing the foot most
of the footwork then doing essentially
the same thing
that they had done in Afghanistan for
the last
four years of the occupation Special
Forces uh some direct action guys but
mostly ukrainians and then drones and
then lots and lots of materials yep lots
of materials military industrial complex
right yeah because that's profitable and
it keeps the population in the U.S happy
because you don't get a lot of body bags
so you get a a bunch of dollars that get
pumped into all the states because of
the way that the military-industrial
complex has broken up the production of
everything the F-35 is made in like
every state in the country every state
has a part that they make so the whole
the government and they do that with all
sorts of different uh products that the
the military industrial complex it
sounds like sustainability yeah the wef
right they spread it across well they
spread it across the country because
Congress people are like oh I want to
get a little piece for my district so
they go ahead and they get they have all
the the production of stuff spread
across across the country you have very
few Americans coming home in body bags
and stimulating the U.S economy by
pumping money into it all across the
country it's a win-win war is a win-win
for the government the universe is
modern war the University of Oklahoma is
explicitly it's in its strategic
research vertical says that you know
Aerospace and defense you know it's
specifically having to do with weather I
don't know exactly how that works but
it's invested deeply heavily and this is
a public state-funded university oh like
controlling the weather to destroy your
opponent or or you know individual
carbon footprint trackers right you know
yeah well yeah then because then they
can tax your carbon they tax they can
prevent you from doing things in the
real world because you've used up your
carbon right so you've used up your
allotment for carbon so any and it could
be whether it be
everyone gets a large amount or more
than likely everyone's going to get a
very very small amount and if you have a
social credit system that's going to be
connected to your carbon usage and they
can basically have a digital Gulag where
they keep you locked in your home or
locked in your 15-minute City and you're
not allowed to go anywhere you're
allowed to but you can't get anywhere
you can't charge your electric car yeah
because you don't have enough carb
you'll have you can't you know have
enough carbon and what will end up
happening is that people will figure out
ways to sell carbon credits and there'll
be a black market for carbon you I
guarantee that because big companies are
going to have carbon credits that
they're gonna that people figure out
ways to siphon off to be a whole new
economy selling carbon to people that
have lots of money and it'll still be
rich people doing whatever the f they
want while the poor in the middle class
well the middle class gets decimated
there'll be fewer in the middle class
and the poor are going to be stuck in
the past all right we'll read uh one
more here cleft the misfit says Akira
Toriyama has said the reason Goku and
others in Dragon Ball Z are blonde as
Super Saiyans is because he got sick of
coloring in their hair that's awesome I
believe it I believe it all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button Smash
It And subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends if you really
do like it it's the best way to help and
become a member at timcast.com because
we are going to launch the members only
live portion of the show it's now live
that means once the live is done it will
exist on the website in the archive
forever you can watch it anytime same as
this podcast but if you want to hang out
live you can do so at timcast.com which
will be up in about 10 minutes and then
uh moving forward hopefully by next week
maybe even tomorrow we will have a
Discord which is a chat server where you
can sign up chat with people all day
every day and then even call into the
show in the members only portion so
again smash that like button you can
follow the show at timcastirl you can
follow me personally at timcast Mark do
you want to shout anything out yeah uh
follow me on my YouTube channel at
unwelcomepod that's without an e in the
middle there and uh you can follow me on
Twitter everywhere I Rumble those places
uh I also got a sub stack it's uh
unwelcome.substack.com you can follow me
there and I'd really appreciate it come
out and hit that subscribe button for me
too that'd be cool
what's up I am Phil that remains on
Twitter I am Phil that remains official
on Instagram the band is All That
Remains uh check us out we do fun stuff
play metal it's sick
yeah Ian Crossland what's up everybody
follow me again crossing.net if you want
to mark that was really fun yeah man I
like talking about theology yeah it's
fun and God that's that's very much
enjoyable you should come on my show and
let's talk about it okay okay let me
know when hit me on Twitter or something
um and the UFO in case you're wondering
is here and will be spun in the future
we just had a little bit of fun with it
who was that yesterday we had on there
Wheezy Wheezy F baby the one and only
anyway this is uh this is an aquamarine
in case anyone's wondering it's it's
refracting the light from below that'll
look pretty cool all right see you later
yeah we've been uh putting interesting
things on the UFO thing so I'll take
credit for that sorry you win uh yeah
I'm at search.com on Twitter
and uh it's oh yeah Phil is motioning me
to say tomorrow we will be on the pop
culture crisis
yeah yeah uh it'll be fun uh it'll be
during the daytime I think it's like two
o'clock three three o'clock Eastern
Standard Time check us out there see you
guys later and uh we'll we'll be live
over at timcast.com if you go to the
home page in about 10 minutes you will
see the members only live click it and
you can watch there's comment system
it's not too great just yet but come
hang out with us and uh it will improve
in the future thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in a few minutes